[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
better
[Music]
all yes way all the way all the way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
better
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come
um
[Music]
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
jesus
[Applause]
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about
magic time
we're in the game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone to pogchamps 3
presented by grip6
we are here in the quarterfinals the
event has been
going by so quickly i'm super excited
but also sad to see it
going by so soon today i'm joined by the
one and only
wfm anna kremling anna how are you
feeling to be here today
i'm so excited to be here today i'm
really pumped about seeing these couple
of matches that we're going to be doing
commentary and
it's my first time doing commentary for
pogchamp so it's really going to be
super exciting
well anna you've already done an
incredible job streaming for those of
you don't know anna has her own stream
and it is super exciting to watch blitz
viewer games educational stuff but
enough of that let's talk about
pogchamps and what the format is going
to be today for people tuning in
as you guys who have been watching know
the format is
single elimination double round robin
which means that the players are going
to go
head to head they're going to play a
game as white and a game as black
and the winner will be moving on today
since we're at the quarterfinals
the loser will be eliminated the time
control
is 10 minutes with a 5 second increment
if they go 1-1 they will go into the tie
breaks which are five minutes with zero
second increment
so that does get a lot faster and the
finals for both the consolation and
championship brackets
are going to take place february 28th
that is four days from now
so we are really gearing up so let's
talk a little bit about what they're
playing for
uh anna these are some pretty generous
prizes
uh what do you have to say for the 60
000 prize in the championship bracket
that's a huge prize that's really
amazing
absolutely the winner is going to get 20
000
even for the consolation bracket we have
a thirty two thousand dollar prize pool
the winner is going to get seven
thousand
and there's also the group stages which
already happened so maybe we'll focus a
little bit less on that
we are at the quarterfinals so the
players who get eliminated today will
walk home with an extra 4 or 3k
in their pocket and you know streamers
really need that extra money so i'm
really really glad this is happening so
let's talk about something a little bit
more meaningful
um we're also doing community outreach
and
what is happening is chess.com is
matching up to a hundred
thousand dollars of the community's
donations during the event
and this is something that i think is
awesome so far
we've raised 18 000 we're very close to
25k so if you guys
do donate um all of the streamers
actually picked a charity they want to
donate to and
and we could show that right now to see
which streamers picked which charities
anna looking at this list are there any
charities that you recognize or you're
excited to see here
i mean i'm just so excited about the
fact that that they're doing this and
that they're picking charities and that
all of this money is going to charity
basically i think that's just absolutely
amazing
and so i don't recognize all of them but
i do recognize them like unicef
saint jude's um
yeah little haiti i recognize no kid
hungry
so i'm really really really happy to see
that
you know the communities are coming
together to to help out these charities
absolutely it's fun to mix entertainment
and give back in one way or another
let's take a look at the championship
brackets so
we already know who is going to make it
into
the semifinals or half of the people uh
benji fishy was able to
take down daniel negranu and sardoche
who is the favorite by raiding in the
tournament was able to take
um xqc down although xqc has made huge
progress since pogchamps won
today we are going to be finding out who
the other two players making it to the
semifinals are
we're going to start with our first
match today which is going to be rayne
wilson
also known as dwight from the office
against moist critical
charlie one of the fan favorites from
the first pog champs
second we're gonna see ludwig versus
logic and ludwig and logic are very
close in raiding
um logics between a thousand to eleven
hundred ludwig is around
eleven hundred thirty so this is gonna
be a very close match it's going to be
the last match of the day i'm
super excited to see these um let's talk
as well about the consolation bracket
we got nico versus rubius and nico
versus rubios are both spanish streamers
have you watched either of the mana
i have i have in fact rubios was
actually born in the same little town as
me in spain which is pretty crazy it's
not it's really not a big town so
it's really awesome to see that he's
participating in this tournament yeah
and
he has had a little bit of a rough start
so far he hasn't won a game yet but he
has had some very close ones
um even ended up having a mouse slip in
one of his earlier games so we know his
chest level is there
maybe he'll have a little bit of extra
luck he is in the 900 to 1000 range
which is what you usually see
as very strong for the consolation
bracket that being said he's playing
against nico
who is around 800 but has been
performing much better than her rating
and was even able to get a draw against
sardoche
the favorite in the tournament so this
is gonna be a super close match
um anna do you want to talk a bit about
pokemane versus myth
yeah i mean i'm super excited about
pokemon she's been grinding a lot of
chess i've been seeing her playing a lot
of chess
and it's amazing to see that she's
really improved and i watched her match
against the
against against xqc and that was a very
very close match as well
also like you mentioned really amazing
to see that xqc has improved so much
from the previous pogchamps that he's
played
and yeah i'm just excited to see what
happens between pokeman and myth
absolutely so today we're going to see
nico versus rubios and pokemane versus
myth this is the schedule so we're going
to start off with rain wilson
versus moist critical then we're going
to go into nico versus rubius
then we're going to be swapping um
grandmaster hikaru and international
master danny
is going to be coming on to cover ludwig
and logic and the last game will be
pokemane versus myth
all of the games today are going to be
super important because one person
is going to get eliminated each time we
are getting very close to the finals
there is no more coming back ladies and
gentlemen the intensity
is here so much pressure exactly
exactly um so i have to ask you do you
think that
uh critical will be wearing or will be
dressed up as dwight just like logic was
when he played against the
rain wilson i love it i mean a lot of
people have been dressing up as dwight
but i did tune into moist critical
stream before commentary and he was
actually dressed
i am i'm actually pretty sure that he
only has white t-shirts in his closet
because he wears that every single time
he was working on his tactics but he did
not look like dwight unless there's some
kind of surprise come in there
we'll have to ask him but yeah i thought
about the same thing about the white
t-shirts i've noticed that too
yeah and we have one more announcement
um
so there's going to be another game on
thursday but it's just going to be
one game so let's uh take a little bit
of a look at that it's going to be taboo
versus code miko
obviously everybody is super busy with
their schedule
and we're trying to get all the
streamers to play on their own time so
this is going to be just one match it's
a little bit different so
that is why we are announcing it um but
with that being said anna
welcome to your first pogchamps
commentary this is going to be super
exciting
everybody watching stay tuned we'll be
right back after a couple
breaks
okay here we go
things that give somebody putting the
prime flashlight
yeah we'll see run bay and thanks snow
did a little prep for rain's wacky
openings with daniel
before the stream uh we'll see if i can
remember the lines but
no telling
but i was doing my homework i did a few
hundred puzzles yesterday
trying to get my tactical sharpness back
[ __ ] honing my senses
actually tier one corby and there's some
good weird
i have to pee again god damn if i leave
during the game
i'll just do like six pre-moves and see
what happens
you'll know why
thanks to tier one liam
makes the reset blue screws and the
prime
rj
hurry and go put a diaper on that
wouldn't help
i don't know how absorbent you think
diapers are they can only handle baby
piss because there's not a whole lot of
it like a baby can't pee
like a man babies are so [ __ ] weak
there's no way a diaper would be able to
contain my fluid
thanks to the prime emma rizzi the resub
juke
and universal
thanks snow
adult diaper nah no such thing that's a
marketing scheme
an adult diaper is just a baby diaper
they just put a different title on it
i'm blowing the lid wide open thanks the
recep don't get worked
you get a catheter no man definitely not
doing a catheter
how is it chess.com always comes in on
these conversations
it's not that frequent but i feel like
every time there is one it's on
chess.com stream
like when we're talking about edible
[ __ ] of chess grandmasters
that's crazy i feel like they do it on
purpose
like in the booth they're like let's
make charlie look like a goddamn idiot
thanks to the gifts of liam the prime
redbeard
it needs to resub faded
i keep moving the time back well how
much time do i have do i have time to go
pee
things with prime glass and there is
some cool beating
your last video is very disrespectful to
pagans and witches
man what in the [ __ ] are you talking
about
are you just you just joyless like you
can't have fun
i didn't go out there and say [ __ ] all
pagans and people that believed their
witches
i didn't call them goddamn idiots or
anything we just had fun
doing goofy spells you think there's
actual like
reason behind sticking toothpicks in a
lemon no it's just fun
stop being so joyless
i'm sure you've you've made plenty of
plenty of jokes about other beliefs as
well
like reptilians or something i'm i'm
sure
it's not as disrespectful as you think i
would imagine the majority can recognize
it's only for fun and i have nothing
against people that believe those things
it's [ __ ] warlock and witches spell
books from party city for god's sakes
jesus christ
anything to be mad about something i
guess god damn
thanks to the prime asap and the gifts
of rafa and the recent poopy
and b13
you're wasting your toilet time it might
make me play better
i'm gonna try one with like a fully
loaded tank here
see how i play and then if i play really
well i'll hold it for the next couple of
games
but if i play like dog [ __ ] i have a
good excuse so it'll be good
exit tier one victor
thanks for the bit saucy
welcome back to pogchamps 3 presented by
grip 6.
we are about to see the quarterfinals
championship bracket match between moist
critical and rain wilson
rayne wilson is the higher rated
opponent here he seems to be playing
around 13 to 1400 strength
moist critical is around a thousand a
thousand a hundred but he has more
experience playing in pogchamps
anna who do you think has the edge
i think it's going to be a very close
match because even even though you said
that you know rain wilson
and he is a bit higher rated i think i'm
always critical has really played some
amazing games and
i've seen him doing a lot of great
training with donya and i don't know i
think he's playing great so i
definitely think that his experience is
going to
lead him to playing a really close match
at least i think that's a great way to
put it i mean we've seen the progress
he's made since the first pog champs
where
if i recall correctly he was around 800
rating or so maybe even 600.
he has been training a lot of chess he
has a consistent
uh lesson schedule with grand master
daniel naraditsky
he also does puzzles by himself and he's
kind of also a super talented gamer
in whatever he takes up yeah
yeah absolutely um and i mean rayne
wilson
he seems to just be a talent for chess
as well a bit i think that he's played
quite a lot in the past
and but but he's been playing some great
chess it's
you can tell that he kind of really
understands what's going on in most
positions and it's going to be really
exciting to see
what he brings today yeah it's very
ominous that he has that um
analog chest clock in the back i mean
he's the kind of guy who
if he still has one of those clocks he
has been playing chess for a really long
time oh my gosh it's intimidating
it's intimidating i mean that's like the
best thing to put in a tournament like
this just show your opponent
look at this i have a clock that's this
old i've been playing chess for
this amount of time get ready yeah i
would love it if one of the players just
put a ton of chest books behind them
just to try to intimidate their opponent
a little bit but it did look like rayne
wilson was
was meditating a little bit he had his
eyes closed do you have any pregame
rituals
i typically i can do two things either
i'll just listen to music
and lay in bed before the game like
right before the game and then i'll run
to the game
or i will just watch some netflix
some funny show or something but the
games are starting real rain wilson is
opening up with
e4 and c5 we see by moist critical
uh okay one second i don't see oh okay
here they are
perfect um all right so moist critical
is playing the sicilian
which is what we saw him play as well
against ludwig
he is comfortable with this opening i
don't know if he prepared specifically
but it's always good
to stick to something you know right
definitely definitely if you stick to
something you know then
the opening is going to feel a lot more
comfortable and you're probably not
going to lose so much time in the
opening as well
and rain wilson decided to play b3 an
old sicilian and a very passive choice
why do you think he's doing this
i mean i think that it's perfect you
know the analog clock
a pretty pretty old sicilian as well um
i mean b3 is is a it's a good move it's
a good choice i guess if he's prepared
something
either he has prepared this or um he
hasn't played it before
and he wants to surprise most critical
it's one of the two but
i think that it's a perfectly decent
move and he's just trying to get his
bishop on the
on the diagonal to control the center
and it did seem that his decision to
play b3
stumped moist critical a little bit
because he just took
43 seconds on that last move i mean it's
move
three you got to be playing a little bit
faster especially if it's a move like
knight f6 but i guess it is important to
be confident with your opening position
absolutely it's really important to to
feel comfortable with your opening
position but
it does seem like rain wilson might have
surprised him a little bit but
you know maybe my critical surprise rain
as well because he took a little thought
there also some 40 seconds
oh my gosh he played e5 this is a bold
move maybe we should take a listen in on
charlie it looks like he's smiling
and saying something interesting
i cannot hear him yet but maybe that's
just because he's shaking his head
the good thing is this is going to block
the bishop here
there you go it's not really that good
of a thing though
oh man he had to retreat his knight that
is not when i push this he pushes this
and i have to tend to this pressure so i
just lose my [ __ ] looking very
passive now the whole king side all the
people
i believe the only play i had well
this is [ __ ] me up man this is
[ __ ] me up
queen take nope there's two attackers on
it
or two defenders on it now i think i
just pushed the pawn
oh no it seems like he's a little bit
stressed out of the opening
um we can we can come back to the main
board now
i i think he he realized that it wasn't
the perfect decision that being said
losing a tempo is not the worst thing in
the world he can still come back from it
but i think the most difficult
part is the psychological challenge of
knowing you've already messed up a
little bit in the first five moves
yeah yeah typically the opening is the
one thing that
the players have prepared and that the
players feel quite
quite comfortable with but if that
preparation sort of
doesn't go so well or they get surprised
or don't
like their position then that
psychologically it's very tough for the
players
although dwight sorry rayne wilson
just made an interesting choice and he
played d4
moist critical can take on e5 force off
all of the trades and then take his
queen on d1
which would cause rain wilson to not be
able to castle
his king later do you think this is a
line you should go for
i think that seems like a good line i'm
also wondering what happens if he
just takes on d4 i'm wondering what
happens then with the pawn on e5 it
seems like it's almost gonna be lost
isn't it
well that is a great sign if critical
can take either pawn and be okay then i
think he's in good shape here
um let's take a listen in and see which
one he's considering
and hopefully he's not totally silent
like he was last time i called this
come on critical you're making me look
bad man say something interesting you're
a god
i've never been in a [ __ ] position
like this
i have this check but it's not really
good because i don't get any pieces for
it
uh like i don't he just blocks it with
his knight maybe
or you could even just push this pawn
maybe i just deliver the check anyway
okay so he's being baited by a feel-good
check that's a little bit concerning
because queen a5 doesn't actually have a
good
follow-up i'm doing it no it's a dumb
check
it's a dump yes it's done wait
why did he do it he just said it was
dumb why did he do it i'm doing it
i've already taken uh a minute 40 on a
single move i'm just gonna play faster
now
uh i think he tricked himself i think my
instinct is way off i'm just
i'm just gonna play fast we're gonna see
what happens oh no
oh no i'm just gonna block like this i
don't think he's gonna move his knight
moving his knight would be wrong that's
typically how it starts well he wouldn't
give me [ __ ] actually
do you think he's in his head anna
i think so yeah
well that was not the most perfect move
here
this knight is pinned looks kind of odd
it also gets rid of this
is on c3 as it's kind of unprotected
there it's only protected by the bishop
but it feels like it could be targeted
quite easily
yeah so once again critical has the
option of taking either
two pawns and they're both gonna give
him a pretty interesting position
if we have knight takes d4 here then the
pawn on e5 is going to be hanging
so critical might actually be able to
win a pawn he can even take the knight
queen takes and queen takes c5 and trade
his queen off the board
um okay so he went for this instead and
the computer
just had a heart attack here what is
going on
what is going on well i mean yeah now
now they're exchanging here
i think it's just because what happens
is just that black doesn't
get that good puns black's pawn
structure is pretty weak
and the pawns on a7 c6 and e5
are kind of which structure looks really
interesting it's
yeah yeah it looks kind of robbie you
know
um critical is famously known
for that um so what what do you think
his plan should be here
chat behave um
yeah so i think that maybe would have
been better to just take with the knight
i think that that's why the
evil bar had a little bit of a heart
attack because
it would just have become a better pawn
structure with the knight but queen of
three is a good move looking at the pawn
and c6 and also maybe
looking a little bit at the pawn on f7
maybe once you bring a bishop to c4
we've seen those type of attacks
yeah and they're really intimidating
attacks they can be stopped even if he
plays something like knight f6 to just
block it
um he'll be okay but the problem is
he's gonna lose his pawn on c6 so is he
willing to give up a pawn here and he
can't do it right away because then
he'll lose his rook
um so i guess he has to first defend c6
he can do that with the bishop and also
develop and then he can protect f7 and
it seems like this is what he's going
for so that's a good sign
and he's going for a long cop i was
going to ask you alex if you thought
that he was going to
castle queenside but he did it before i
could ask you
oh my gosh he is castling queenside this
is really bold his rook is on the open
file now
and he has so much peace activity that
this is
actually helping him i like it i'm gonna
give him style points for this what do
you think
i love it i would have done the exact
same thing i think he sort of tricked us
you know
playing this b3 move that was kind of
passive we thought it was going to be a
kind of long game maybe but he's just
playing in a very aggressive style i
love it
yeah he's like a slow mastermind a
master of deception and of chess
rayne wilson he looks like it as well
just look at his face he does look like
a master
yeah yeah he does give me master vibes
he's just so focused it looks like it
could be a photo of him he hasn't
moved he is focusing all of his energy
towards sending blood to his brain
and he's just on overdrive right now so
i really like the vibe he's going for
but what about charlie charlie has been
working so hard
he has all of his pieces here he's gonna
have to try very desperately to develop
but he does have chances of unwinding
he does he does he just needs to get his
knight bishop out and then he just needs
to get his king to safety
and whenever he's done all those things
then
he'll be fine basically just needs to be
able to do them without
facing any horrible consequences
absolutely and
the other move he could consider is
bishop a3 to create a pin
on the bishop on b2 and you know it's
not like white actually has to take or
even if
black ends up taking there isn't really
a clear breakthrough in the fortress
but at least he's removing a piece from
the king's defense and helping himself
develop a little bit faster i totally
agree i like bishop a3 i also like
bishop b4 maybe
to threaten what crazy move this
computer is smoking
tell me knight b5 knight b
nobody's gonna play knight b5 because
you can't take because the bishop on b7
is is hanging so
that's all the computer lines i'm to
have to see for today
i had to check goes knight b5 now then
i think that we can just shake his hand
basically that would be
that would be an amazing move to find by
him yeah this is going to be the touring
test
um if i guess touring tests
proves that no it would prove that he's
a computer it would be the opposite of
it um if dwight sees it sorry
if rayne wilson i really like the office
that's why i keep saying it i'm so
i sorry get that anyway
i think most of most of most of people
just think of him as dwight
oh i mean it must be exhausting to have
played a character that is so
much larger than life that people
associate
with you with the character for the rest
of your life
yeah definitely definitely i actually
haven't seen the office
so that's why i'm not calling him dwight
because i don't have it in my
in my blood basically as i haven't seen
it but
i've heard it's a great great show well
i'm i'm glad to hear that rookie won
also a good choice if he wasn't able to
find that crazy tactical move
i love that he's just bringing in all of
his pieces to the attack
how should critical continue here i
think he needs to bring his night out as
soon as he can that king cannot stay in
the center for too long otherwise
that'd be dangerous yeah so maybe knight
f6
nice blocking move for the queen here
and once he castles i think what's
important is that he's gonna feel a lot
more comfortable
comfortable because he was so behind
development and he's finally
safe but he has half of reigns time
do you think he'll be able to hold up
under the time pressure i mean i think
that both people
are or both players have quite low time
for the amount of moves that have been
played only 13 moves have been played
this is still the opening
and this is almost becoming a blitz game
so i think that
definitely we're gonna feel the time in
this game yeah
and i would say we could check out
critical stream but he is
really focused i don't think he's
talking right now because
whenever he gets into time pressure he
goes full
focus mode we're taking a look anyways
just in case
oh he is very aware of his time
situation and i think he took the bishop
on b2 just because he wasn't sure
what to do yeah that's typically a very
easy or
it's it's very common to do that wow
queen g3 attacking upon g7
you saw that oh my gosh he played that
so quickly and the problem is
charlie can't defend both the e5 pawn
and the g7 pawn
yeah and that g7 pawn is a huge pawn
because it's also attacking the rick
yeah and he can't even oh man he doesn't
really have
he doesn't have options here
i don't know he's gonna defend it
because if he goes
d6 then
yes he did go for g6 he's gonna have to
trade the queens
if queen takes five but i'm out of time
to think of something about rick takes
c5 though
attacking the queen and then looking at
the rook on b8 with that queen
yeah rook takes e5 is certainly the most
accurate move here
um and you know with reigns play so far
i would not be surprised at all if he
takes with the rook here
playing so well wow wow jinx yeah this
is
i mean he is a heavy hitter for sure
just a blunder
no way protected by the queen i didn't
even notice
he's playing so well yeah yeah and it is
sad to hear
um you know kind of i
i think in his voice you can hear that
critical noise the position has been
really tough
he sounds a little bit defeated and now
rook takes c6 is going to win the queen
but hopefully hopefully he doesn't give
up because even if
this game isn't going his way he can
come back in the next one
definitely definitely that's the
important thing that he doesn't
uh that he doesn't give up with the next
game right do you do you think rain is
gonna see rook takes e6 here
i think that ring can see almost
anything no he didn't see that oh
wow he is giving charlie another chance
here
um and what charlie can do now is trade
off queens and then develop
or give a queen for free
oh no
no oh my god
no i can't believe i just did that
oh no
oh whoops i was so focused on castling
oh whoops
uh-oh i'm happy to see that he's
laughing though
yeah i mean laughs laugh through the
pain right
yeah well i'm just gonna go back one
move
so he really could have recovered here
he could have taken the queen
and then he would only be a little bit
behind in development but his peace
advantage
sorry the material advantage was fine
for both
so he did miss it but he was very low on
time
yeah he definitely was and we can see
how important the time became there but
that's what happens sometimes you just
focus on one plan he he said it you know
that he's just thinking about castling
but
yeah forget about your other pieces
and the funny thing is that rayne wilson
looks
unfazed he looks like he just eats 1200s
for breakfast or something i mean he's
like uh yeah just another morning
just another queen hanging in puck temps
exactly exactly he's like i'm just gonna
attack the queen and these fog jumps
participant tend to give it to him so i
mean i guess i would do the same thing
he has the exact same face as he had
before he took the queen it's actually
hilarious
i know i know um
so even if he plays rook d7 here and
sacks on e6 he can go for some very
fancy checkmate tactics it would be nice
to see him
just put a little ribbon on this
position and get a clean
winning tactic yep that would be very
nice
he just uh he should probably just not
focus on making it too beautiful because
sometimes when
when we focus on that i know that i've
done it in games then
all of a sudden i've just sacked all my
pieces because i thought there was some
beautiful checkmate and then my pieces
were gone and there was no checkmate
well what advice would you give to
critical it seems like
he's not in his best form today i know
he's very capable and he can play much
better than he did
i think that he should just get over
this game like just sort of like they
just laugh at himself a little bit and
you know what happened and then
just say okay rain has won the first
game
but there's another game and if i win
that game then i mean it's it's 1-1 and
we're taking it to the next
uh to next match so i think that he just
needs to focus on the next one after
this and not dwell too much about this
game
yeah um and
on on top of that i think his coach gm
nero diskey is
watching i know he was last time um
and he he had this line that i still
didn't forget
when critical missed a free queen in his
game against ludwig and he said
i'm not mad i'm just disappointed
i i don't know why i'm bringing down the
mood and saying that
but the whole point is
we have really high hopes for critical
he has been improving so quickly
and uh you know what i think he's gonna
make dania proud in the second game
i think so too and then maybe he will
have to hear that
wait oh my gosh rain wilson almost
repeated the position three times i
think he was just trolling
do you think he did it on purpose uh
maybe to maybe to gain time it's okay to
repeat the position twice i guess and
then leave on the third
one yeah you see that's one of
that's one of the ways that this
position could be drawn i mean apart
from stalemates
in this game a position can also be
drawn if we have the same position three
times
and it's not completely uncommon that
that happens
right and do you agree with critical
continuing to play here
well i think that i mean obviously this
is probably completely lost but i don't
see anything wrong with continuing to
play this position here
like i love the way you phrase that
i mean it's obviously completely lost
but why not no i
i agree with you whenever there's a
chance especially
in a tournament where you know you're in
the quarterfinals you want to give it
everything you have
yeah and even if it's just to like
get over this game like sometimes when
you play the last games in a
or the last moves in a game you kind of
feel okay about the fact that you're
gonna lose and so if this like sort of
makes him accept
his loss then i think there's nothing
wrong with that before he goes into the
next game
yeah absolutely and on a more positive
note we got a really lovely donation
from i play
chess because of ludwig somebody donated
a hundred dollars he said
love from india if ludwig goes to the
semifinals i'm donating 200
thank you so much um for the donation we
really appreciate you
supporting the streamers favorite
charity and i'm glad you've been
enjoying the show
thank you um maiden five
well i i don't think we're gonna see
that but
rain wilson's position is unstoppable
now oh and critical resigned
yeah well i i don't blame him the
position was very difficult
to save and he did give it his best i
really hope he's able to
shake off the bad feeling from this loss
and come back in the next game
i really hope so too and it's going to
be it's going to be really exciting to
watch the next match i mean
even though he lost this game he
blundered a queen i still think that the
next match could be a very close one and
it's going to be really exciting to
follow that
absolutely well you guys we are going to
be taking a really quick break and then
we will be back with pogchamps three
quarter finals presented by grip six
i saw daniel's message hey man
hey uh thanks for thanks for calling me
i'll be really quick
so first of all keep your head up second
of all
um i feel like
you know i feel like you're not
believing to your core
that you can win the game and if i
thought that that was the case i would
have told you before the round
that i think your chances aren't very
good i didn't tell you that
and um you need to stick to the
fundamentals
so what was what was going on that game
what were you what were you feeling
uh well the second that he played the
b-pawn
i was lost because i've never seen that
in the dragon 94
here's the thing charlie you're good
enough to where you improvise perfectly
and after he played move six d4 you
wha if you take that pawn you're better
you take c takes d4 and if he plays
knight takes d4
you do you do what move seven uh
so if i had taken his d4 pawn yes which
is what you should have done
and he plays knight takes d4 that's a
free pawn lying by the side of the road
oh i see what can you take away just
take it with the pawn
or even with the knight to preserve your
pawn structure
okay i see rain
is he hasn't analyzed any he's bluffing
you
completely and you can't trust a single
thing he does now the remove queen a5
check
you're not developing your pieces right
you're bringing your queen out early
then um on move 11
i wasn't sure why you weren't developing
your knight we talked about it nights
before bishop so you have to get your
king side down i can't go back
knight f6 move 11. um how do i go back
because now i'm stuck on this line oh
you got to call the game up in your game
industry i'll
i'll i'll invite you one sec oh hold on
i think the next fight the next game is
probably going to start pretty soon
development move 14 you moved your rock
put the emphasis on development just say
f it don't trust a single thing he does
every move he makes what is he
threatening let me get my pieces out
castle quickly remember the line and um
he's going to blunt or something he's
very sloppy
and uh you have the fundamentals in you
to improvise
whatever he does okay all right sounds
good
believe i believe in you and uh just uh
give it your all
all right sounds good man thank you
we're all here for you good luck good
luck i'll let you i'll let you prepare
yeah i mean the second that uh i took
what was it
[ __ ] three minutes on one of the
moves and then delivered this
check which i said was bad in the first
place i knew it was kind of [ __ ] and
then i did this and it ended on the spot
when i played this and he did this and
didn't take it ended
on the spot exit 5 you subs translate
ah what a spanking
welcome back to pogchamps 3 presented by
grip6
that was such a wholesome exchange
between coach grandmaster daniel
naradiski
and his student moist critical you can
tell that
daniel was really caring about his
results here but also that
critical wasn't playing to the best of
his ability and a large part of his last
game i think was that he wasn't
believing in himself because he is able
to play
so much better um than what we just saw
anna what are your thoughts
i just have to say me and alex were just
in awe during the break hearing that
that was so wholesome and yeah i think
that was great that he got to hear these
words of encouragement
by his coach he's a great coach
and i think that it's so so so important
to
to encourage and it's very important
that he called was critical to encourage
him because
like you said alex it seemed as if he
didn't really believe in himself in that
game
and i think that he just needs to
believe in himself to play a great game
we've seen him play great before
so they're going to start the next game
now e4 d64
all right and also this is not to
um say anything against rayne wilson
because we obviously want the best
player to win but it would be great to
see both players
you know being able to feel like they
were playing their best chess and they
weren't in their heads so that's what
we're hoping to see here
and critical is basically playing what
we teach
all opening all beginners to do in the
opening put your pawns in the center
develop your pieces and rain wilson is
playing a perk
which is a king's indian if it's against
a d4 and it's a very strategic
system to play so it could be very
uncomfortable if he hasn't studied it
too much what are your thoughts on the
perk
as a beginner to be honest i don't play
too much of the perk but
i mean i think that it seems it seems to
be a great position you're developing
your bishop to g7 you're getting that
bishop and controlling the whole
diagonal putting pressure on the center
on the pawn on d4
and it seems like if reign likes to
fianchetto's bishops to get them
out that way so maybe this is just you
know a great opening for him
i actually think that everybody's just
super intimidated
by rain everybody trusts him and his
moves so much definitely yeah i think
it's just because we've seen him playing
so good games but he's also at some
point he's missing some moves so
even though he is a great player his
opponents do have a chance against him
and i think that it's important for his
opponents to to
to feel like even though they're playing
as a great player they have a chance to
win
and it's always been the lookout for
those chances
absolutely and i will say though i don't
love the e5 move
not because it's necessarily wrong but
it feels to me like
critical is trying to compensate a
little bit for the last game it's a very
aggressive move
it would have been nice to see him get a
good position out of the opening
something like knight f3 castle just so
you know he's able to make sure that
he'll be okay after the last round
this is this needs to be preparation
yeah yeah i totally agree i think it's
good that he feels like he
oh i'm sorry it's preparation he studied
this with daniel naradiski so he knows
what he's doing actually
if it's preparation that's entirely
different
yeah that's awesome that's awesome and
he's playing this super fast as well
it seems as if he he looks a lot more
confident i feel like
yeah i mean you know when jesus has the
prophet whispering
in his ear nobody can stop him he looks
a lot more confident right now
i actually love that people call
critical chess jesus
and that they call daniel naradiski the
prophet it's very funny
it's actually so funny yeah um
and yeah we're we're gonna see what
uh we're gonna see if he if he does a
jesus like game basically
yeah exactly and for once we see that
rain wilson is actually the one who is
taking his time
and he played knight g4 so he is putting
pressure
on e5 how do you think white should
continue here
there are two options to defend e5 or
actually there are quite a lot i was not
66
it was one of those options but um i
mean this seems like he's still it's
still preparation so
yeah he played it really quickly and
confidently e6 looks like a very strong
move black cannot take
i mean he can take and bishop takes with
check oh my god he just lost a piece
that's a piece he's gonna lose the
knight on g4
and then critical's king is still in the
center of the board but he should be
just
up a pure piece here he should be able
to just get his knight and castle as
well
pretty pretty nicely after that
oh my gosh i mean uh narediski's
pep talks are worth their weight in gold
okay
something really powerful is going on
here
and rain does not look afraid
at all as usual but do you think he
realized his mistake
i think so i think that that hand move
you know yeah
the way he's putting his hand over his
mouth
you know really tickling the nostrils a
little bit um
thinking think about what he's gonna do
because he's realized that he's losing a
piece
here in the opening well he's also
really low on time
um i don't even know what is the what is
the trickiest thing he can go for
he could maybe try taking on f2 and
at least that way when he recaptures the
bishop he'll have some kind of counter
play because
again criticals king is in the center of
the board so if you are in a position
like this
don't be hurry to just take try to see
if you have any other options and he
goes for 95 instead
yeah he goes for 95. i kind of prefer
the move that you said alex to take on
f2 because
that would just sort of bring the king
to the center and make sure that he
couldn't really castle perhaps
um or at least open up the center a bit
more and the king would become weaker so
95 i feel like just gives
amway's critical this nice comeback of
the bishop
and he's just going to be a piece up
right he just has to retreat the bishop
to any safe square and he's going to be
okay
as long as he doesn't blitz this out
perfect bishop e3
his position is just much better now
he's up
a full piece sorry a piece for a pawn
so two point value but he also has no
weaknesses in his
position yeah and he has three minutes
more in time i think that this is
exactly what he needed for this game to
to really feel confident and to put
rain and some pressure and now this is
going to be one of the more
difficult positions that uh rain has
been faced with
i'm curious do you have any
recommendations for what
he should do here given that he's a
piece down
i think that he should attack as much as
possible if he starts exchanging pieces
or plays passively it's going to be very
easy for
most critical he just got attacked i
would go h5
and you know just bring his pieces out
and and go full in
full attack mode you would just start
flinging pieces and hope that something
sticks right
kind of yeah you do when you're losing
in material i feel like
absolutely and it looks like he is
taking your advice because he pushed c5
he can't go c4 right away because that
square is
attacked by the bishop and the queen but
maybe if he goes to something like a6
and b5 he could try to trap critical's
bishop especially since critical
is going to be distracted trying to get
his king into safety
yep yep i totally agree i think that
he's creating a great plan and
it's nice to see that even though he's
lost a piece he still
wants to play actively and he still
wants to put moist critical under
pressure
so i really like that c5 move that he
just played
yeah me too and knight c6 the fact that
his instincts are
to keep as many pieces on the board that
is a very good way to try to
salvage this position and luckily for
critical he could just continue his
development something like knight f3
and he's not in any trouble yet
nope this looks like a great position
knight of three castles rook the one
just bring those those pieces to the
center and play the game basically
i think it's going to do that it is
always
crazy to see rayne wilson in in such a
hard position i know that he
he has lost two games in pog champs so
far
the one with michelle care was i think a
mouse slip or something where he ended
up giving a piece so he shouldn't have
lost that
but he did lose a game against logic so
he is defeatable just
a very very hard opponent
but voice critical is in a great
position to
win the third game that somebody was
wearing against ray wilson in pogchamp
so
uh it's going to be really exciting to
see if he's able to do that i think that
i think that from seeing how moist
critical has played before that he has
really great chances of winning this
game
and that would make it really exciting
because then he would finish up in 1-1
and what i like is that critical is
not playing too hurriedly he is taking
his time
and one thing that sometimes people do
is they get overconfident and they make
mistakes but he
is making sure that that's not the case
absolutely i like the maverick one but i
think it's really important for him to
really
bring his night out in castle pretty
soon and that's something that he
said in his previous game that he was
just really focused on castling
i think he's going to do that very soon
but it's important that he does it
right and now it's going to get a little
bit tricky queen 85 i love
from rain because he is putting pressure
on c3 and he's starting to cause a
little bit of tension that's gonna be
his only hope here
um and now i'm worried that critical is
not gonna go for f through knight f3
because he's gonna be too distracted
defending his knight and the longer
he prolongs it um the more chances rain
is going to come up with some kind of
counter play
yep we can see that rain is trying to
come up with counter play after every
single move rick the one queen a5
great move so it's still very tricky
even though he's a piece up he's got to
play well the whole game and just like
you said a lot of times
players get really overconfident i do it
all the time if i'm a piece up i'll just
get super overconfident and then
i'll realize that oh wait i it's still a
game you know
it's still you still gotta play a good
game so it's important for moist
critical to
realize that right well let's take a
listen on critical because i'm worried
it's the opposite for him and that he's
still
um doubting himself despite being up a
piece
based on what we saw last round let's
see if he's uh talking here or maybe
he's on full focus mode
yeah i think he's fully focused you
don't see critical completely silent
very often in his stream that's how you
know it's a super intense moment for him
to
do what come in here
maybe just break the pin to be safe
okay so he played bishop d2 and
it's nice that he's developing and
breaking the pin
yep you just gotta make sure to not play
too passively and
start getting a little bit too scared
chatters what do you think the result of
this game is going to be
i know we have some people doing
predictions hype who you think is going
to win
i think it would be very fun if critical
is able to win with a piece up and then
it goes into the tie breaks i'm curious
if rain wilson has a lot of blitz
experience
i'm curious about that too i think it
would be very fun
and you know for all of us watching it
would also be really really fun to take
this to thai
breaks and it's always fun to watch some
faster speed controls faster time
control
such as blitz so that would be super fun
but tell us in the chat who do you think
is going to win
i i will say though that rain will i
think he's just doing that so the night
doesn't have to be the one to protect it
rayne wilson has won for me all of his
tie break games also takes
the pressure off of this i think i just
developed knight in castle
yay develop good job good job awesome
now the king will be safe now daniel is
breathing a little bit more easily i'm
sure
how do you feel daniel's emotions are
watching this game as a coach
i think that he's sitting with his face
super close to the computer looking at
every single move
and feeling the tension but um
yeah he's a great coach i think that
he's really done an amazing job with
with moist critical i have to say that
and on top of that
critical has just done an incredible job
as a student
and i know we have a lot of people in
the chess community who are helping
um these participants with coaching but
honestly
you know at the level they're at what
really matters the most is that
is the effort they're putting in so i
want to make sure that you know
everybody is getting
the credit and of course daniel has been
a fantastic guide but charlie has also
been
a great student so for sure lots of love
for that
yeah absolutely absolutely he's been an
amazing student and
something that i've been so happy about
to see in this pog champs and you know
with every part champs but
is the fact that uh all the people are
participating they really seem to want
to improve at chess and they've spent so
much time
uh during their streams or you know even
even off stream
just trying to improve and playing games
and it's been really amazing to see all
the time that they put in
yeah and in this position now critical
has
developed and he's finished all of his
easy ideas
he is getting very close to rain
wilson's time what do you think his
easiest
strategy to just secure the win would be
well he's got to make sure to not lose
the bishop on b3 after c4
because it's trapped after that move but
um
i would say that i don't know if there's
any tactics right now but
um i mean even like a move like a4 i
think
a3 or a4 just to really make sure that
bishop on b3 never gets trapped would be
a good move i think
yeah and i was actually so distracted
looking at this potential pin that
i didn't even call out the fact that
there is a huge threat in this position
c4 is very scary and he has to make sure
to not fall for this because then all of
a sudden the game
will be even again
yeah absolutely absolutely and it's
really easy to when you see a pin like
this to just focus on the pin but
um rain has some of his attacks the rain
attacks i feel like there's always an
attack with rain wilson
absolutely you know what would be really
cute here if he played
94 attack the queen and then c3 to make
space for his bishop
but i don't want him to spend you know a
minute or two thinking about that
because even if he finds the perfect
variation here and he gets into time
pressure it's not going to be worth it
it's not going to be worth it time
pressure can really
lead to losing any peace or blundering
and okay that's good
that's a great move oh he's attacking c5
and the queen
critical is uh getting some claps for
that one
big claps for that one that's an amazing
move wow knight a4 he's been doing his
puzzles
he has he was working on puzzles before
pog champs
he does a lot of chess grinding streams
he plays slow games
he analyzes them he has been putting the
work and it's nice to see that
um he's getting some tactics in his
games
yep it's really really amazing to see
that and it's such a good feeling to get
a tactic like this
in a game it makes you feel makes you
feel really good and
he didn't win a piece here but at least
he
saved his bishop and these pawns are
going to be weak later on
um one thing he could do is something
like queen c4 to just put pressure
on the pawn and basically try to get a
little bit more material and go for the
trades and simplification
yeah that's exactly what he needs to try
to do he needs to try to go for trades
and simplification
because in any type of end game he's
always going to be winning
as he is at piece up so how would how
would you continue here alex
i also like a3 a lot i think it's an
intuitive move
because he's focused on the pin right
now and whenever you're pinning a piece
if the piece that is pinned has another
way to be attacked
especially by a piece of equal or lower
value you should go for it so a3
is what pops the mind or queen c4
because getting your queens off the
board
when you're up a piece is usually going
to give you a much easier plan
i totally agree i really like both of
those moves a3 really seems like a very
intuitive move
now that you have your bishop on d2
pinning that pawn so
i really like that man we're gonna see
what he plays but he's gotta speed up
pretty soon because he is getting
really low on time and you'd be very sad
to lose a game due to
time trouble yeah come on charlie two
minutes and 12 seconds
he just has to be a little bit faster um
i always get nervous for the players
when they're in time pressure in good
positions
yeah i i think a lot of chess players
can really sympathize with having lost
winning positions because you're down on
time and it is not a good feeling
it definitely is not if you lose a game
because you've really just been
outplayed then you know that's
that's one thing but if you lose because
of
your time that really does hurt so i'm
totally with you
all right and he plays bishop e3 so this
is similar to the idea we were talking
about where he's putting pressure on the
c5
pawn i love it um my only concern
is he has two minutes and it's not just
the clock situation
but there's no clear plan here it is a
very tactical position where he's just
gonna have to keep
trying to attack pieces so it's not the
kind of position you can play
very quickly and not risk blundering
i totally agree yeah that's that's the
main issue and reign has done a great
job at creating a position like this
that's so tricky to play and made making
sure that
there's no simplification so he's done a
great job and he's playing fast as well
he is and he plays 95 which i really
don't like because
critical can take it bishop takes and
then bishop c5 discovery attack on the
bishop and the rook
that variation looks winning for
critical and it's very intuitive to
calculate the trade it definitely is it
definitely is it's going for it
immediately there's nothing wrong with
that
uh but yeah taking on e5 was a really
strong move as well
i i wonder what's happening because
you know rain i i i always get surprised
when i see rain
fall for these kinds of mistakes and
then i have to remember he's also
human and just because he is an
incredible player doesn't mean that
people don't slip up that's true
everybody slips up even the best
of the grandmasters sleep up all the
time so
definitely yes the best grandmasters and
the best
assistants rayne wilson i'm glad you
ended up getting that management
position at the end
um oh gosh did i just give a spoiler
no i didn't okay back to the game um
oh queen of no maybe you cannot go
okay that was a little bit too fast by
me i think oh yeah he he is
he's playing very fast even though he's
not the one in time pressure
let's see what critical thing he just
takes with the knight
but that's good for me i'm up quite a
bit so here
take take
simplification nice
very nice that's exactly what you should
go for
i'm hanging this but it's just the pawn
right now
if i can get observation oh i could have
just came i could have just come right
in
he did have checks oh my god oh my
[ __ ] god i could have just went right
in relax relax charlie oh no
okay oh no oh my [ __ ] god
do we have mulligans in this tournament
this is a great position
oh [ __ ] he moved his queen
i could have just went straight in
oh no oh no
don't beat yourself up
charlie focus what are the odds that i
get away with this if i play this
will it bait him enough to take it
because this is me if i can get this in
here charlie
because he can't block it if i can get
him here
oh no he can block right here but it's
still good i need him to stay here
actually
how do i get him to stay there how do i
get him to stay realize his time
situation maybe coming over here for a
chance
he takes i mate i'm running
time
oh i just gave him an out too
and oh boy oh he just take it and take
it
he didn't see it i got lucky but yeah i
just gave him a heart out there
[ __ ] oh oh
he's getting back in the cycle beating
himself up just retreat you're right
it's rough
it's fine oh my god
i don't want to see danya's reaction
right now but actually
if we had it it'd be interesting to
bring on stream
um very fun oh man
yeah let's check out danya g6 f4
stopping
stopping 95 i like that move there is
increment
but now rain now rain's gonna go knight
c5 i can't believe rain didn't take that
[Music]
donya's actually smiling through right
now
yep how do you play knight f6
is just unbelievable
um all right well we're we're back um
we're we're back okay so
look oh free night free night
yes he's back
these players are they are they are they
friends
what's going on here is this for content
i have no idea but but it is going to
take on e6
too oh if he takes on e6
dania might forgive him dania might
forgive him if he takes on e6
g4 okay all right bring the queen out
that's fine
he has 25 seconds oh no he's
sure to not lose the brick in any way
with something like king h1
or queen c6 can you go back uh
nope he lost the rook um
you can go queen g2 or bishop or bishop
d5
no you're right bishop you know no queen
g2 and take the rook you're right i
don't know i suggested that ah
okay difficult to see it is it is
um he can he should still fight here
though
it's just a clock situation it's not
over
oh no he's he's not looking at the clock
oh no
oh no go go go go go
six seconds come on just any move just
don't flag
uh now rainey's gonna play super fast as
well
he's putting pressure he has some
chances he could he could go for an
attack
get out of your head and just do your
best critical and
yep f5 bishop takes d5 i mean moves like
that could lead to a great attack
nine seconds i think queen takes d5 now
that's great
yep he's putting pressure on f7 best
move here and there's no checks
so he has to start thinking what he's
going to do after
reign defends the pawn what is he going
to do
he's got to go for it what do you like
sorry
um i kind of like f5 maybe i don't know
if you can do that he has to try that he
has eight
seconds he has to go for the aggressive
play and he
does critical with the action-packed
moves
let's let's i don't think he's talking
because the time um pressure is so
intense but let's take a look at a
stream anyway
hopefully he's thinking on rayne
wilson's time that's a really good
tactic if you're low on time but your
opponent is a huge
time i had the game dead for rights at
one point i just didn't see it until
it's time to put yourself
down
come on [ __ ] is so sore
oh god uh
take on f7
game is gonna give me a heart attack
me too oh wow is there a repetition now
if he wants to but it's not enough for
him because he needs to win
exactly he needs to win and uh there is
checkmate queen h3
i don't know if oh rain missed it rain
missed it you're chilling
escape he missed maiden one oh my gosh
all right well critical is i i mean
it's a wild game it's a very wild game
okay he's going
back oh man
oh boy we're gonna have to trade i think
just run just run don't flag don't put
queen f3 no boat has gambits please
king's gotta run
yeah i think king h3 would be checkmate
with queen h1
yep good he saw it king g one he's not
getting mated
unfortunately he's in a worse position
but at least he's not getting mated and
he knows that he can't go for a draw
there there could still be traps
look at that king on h6
i mean rain is playing this very well i
mean he's missed a few things but
still overall it seems like he is the
stronger player
which i think we we've been able to
notice
i can't even think about the best place
to put my [ __ ] king
this is a disaster it seems like he kind
of understands the position
oh okay it's almost getting under a
minute
the second i played my night i saw it
too
the [ __ ] second i played my night
you can tell that critical is turning
into a chess player because he's
spending half his time beating himself
up it's a very classic chess player
thing to do
i can't kiss everyone just do it
oh no now he's i guess it's a draw
because it's opposite-colored bishops
but he has no more winning chances now
unless
he somehow tricks reign and gets his
pawn on a5 but
he'll probably end up i don't know let's
see what happens what do you think
i think that this is it looks like a
draw but at the same time i feel like i
need to hold
i don't know different color here i
don't know if it's gonna end up in a
draw anything can still happen
yeah i mean theoretically it is a draw
but it's honestly been a wild time today
and i
don't even know what to think i mean if
he draws he loses so he might as well go
for the risky play of getting his king
to b5 and trying to win and promote and
sacking his bishop
again he'll probably end up losing but
you you gotta try right you gotta try
yeah you should not go for the
repetition here i don't think
even if raw is there
is the theoretical result here right um
bring the king up but what i what he is
doing well
is he's oh now he takes okay
so so reign is giving him some chances
he he can't move his king right away he
has to move the bishop first i hope he
brings he has to bring in the king he
has to understand this end game
technique if he has a chance
okay uh
it's like it's difficult sometimes to
remember that you gotta really bring in
the king that the king is such an
important
piece in these same games because
without the king
yeah we can see how active the black
king got here now
yep all right well
well i now he might king b5
it's a dance of kings rain wilson and
moist critical
the two left in the ballroom the last
ones after everyone's
left the stage who will get
the last dance that made no sense just
like this game
we're all confused about everything why
not give me five
no oh that was a pawn that had to be
no no
no oh no
do we have a danya cam i really want to
see the daniel camp
i just i'm not saying it's funny when
danya molds but can we see the dummy
again
what's he saying it is a draw
um still but the problem i was still
hoping maybe he'd win or something
okay draw offer by charlie the rain
should just take it
i mean range should just take it it wins
the match for him and it is a draw
drawn position but of course
i was still harboring some hopes that uh
perhaps
bishop blunder might happen
oh okay well i who do you think
would be sadder if he gets knocked out
critical or his coach i think critical
still
i mean chas just feels so somehow
personal in a way and you know you're
putting all your effort into one game
and obviously you get kind of sad when
you lose so
i think it's it's going to be more
critical but he's taking it well like
he's laughing
and smiling yeah all right well they
agreed
on the draw um which makes sense because
reign was winning
and he's going to make it into the
semi-finals now that he has knocked
critical
out of the competition and we know that
critical really
was hoping that he would face ludwig in
the final but
even if it's not pogchamps three maybe
they'll have that happen in pogchamps
four
we'll be right back with a post-game
interview after this short break
you know it's not and the thing is not
that you didn't play well it's
purely a non-chess issue it is purely a
confidence issue
purely a confidence issue because this
is a position he would win
800 times out of 800 and that is a good
thing not a bad thing
so the guy he has potential
will have to work very in a very
substantive way on his confidence
um and uh it hurts for sure it's painful
the last couple days have been painful
but uh
he's gonna hold his head up high that's
that's for sure as he should
um as he should
and uh the problem also was that i think
when he realized that he missed rook d8
thank you james dino for the 600 bits i
think that
when he realized rook d8 um
was a thing as according to you guys he
he freaked out which is a common thing
you know you think about oh i missed it
how did i miss it you know i'm so stupid
all this stuff runs through your mind
and it
interferes with your play spartan thank
you so much
thank you ryan i appreciate it well i
have the easy job he's got
he's he's in front of the crowd
obviously it's always easy from this
there's a russian expression and you
know it's always easy from the side
to criticize and stuff and to say well i
should have seen it how does he miss
this but
yeah um with the shows it doesn't matter
how many subscribers you have
followers chess is
a very very stressful game
yeah thank you mate 1211.
he's come so incredibly far the fact
that we have these expectations for him
is incredible reigns a good player and
uh
you know it was close now i don't know
what this means charlie is out of the
tournament or does he play
the loser of another match does anybody
know
he's out okay well that was a great run
and he made it to the winner's bracket
and uh it's unfortunate
he had a chance here he was winning out
of the opening
um but he'll be back and i hope this
doesn't
i hope this doesn't disawait him from
continuing to be completely honest
um i actually think this can motivate
him to continue
well that was a freaking roller coaster
i'm taking it all in
nothing to be ashamed of obviously
yeah pogchamps four five champs four
here we come let me let me message him
one second my keyboard died actually
thank you sabzam and jonathan for the
thousand bits thank you so much
yeah i messaged him one sec i need to
charge my keyboard
i need a couple deep breaths myself
yeah and this is a a great lesson for
people who can see
uh you know that how much of a role
psychology plays in chess
yeah but clearly the mistakes were
psychological
well anyways um but thank you guys all
for the
incredible support throughout truly we
had the most viewers i've ever had by
by a country mile um
yeah i think we might all partake in
that
um yeah i mean
you know i we're in this for them this
is a marathon rather than a
sprint as they say and to be fair if you
would have won this game there would
have still been the playoff like
we are back we're joined by rain wilson
and
moist critical rain wilson
congratulations you are making it to the
semi-finals
critical oh oh
uh are you uh are you inspired
rain by critical's hair
yeah that's probably what that is yeah
i'm the new
i am the new chest jesus
[Laughter]
oh my gosh critical he's coming for your
game and your personality what do you
have to do
no he's gonna have to really commit to
it no showers for three days i gotta be
able to see the grease on the webcam
the white t-shirt as well the white
t-shirt as well yeah
absolutely well i asked you
i was gonna ask if uh if if you was
great if you charlie if you were gonna
dress up like like dwight just like
logic did but
it's the other way around it's rain
dressing up like you i know
i should have cosplayed i guess damn i
should actually come out here and larped
real quick
well i tell you that was a
nerve-wracking man these games don't get
easier i was
stressed out in that second game man
moist critical had me against the ropes
the whole time
it was all i could do and um i thought i
was going to win on time but then he
just kind of kept playing
a speed game the whole last part and i
couldn't get him on time and
um he just played he played great i got
lucky
so i got lucky you accepted the draw i
was ready to just commit to make this
like dr strange and keep you in a time
loop all day so i'm glad that you
offered a draw i couldn't see a way to
victory
was there a way for me to win without
that last setup you guys
it's actually a theoretical draw when
you have opposite colored bishops even
if you're up upon and i was actually
going to ask if you guys have seen any
of these kinds of end games before i've
never seen one i i was just going off
pure
raw primal neanderthal instincts
critical were you intimidated by rain
because i feel like in your first game
you're kind of in your head a little bit
and
we know that you can play a lot better
than um some of the
queen well okay with the queen blender
we saw what was going on
yeah that was a disaster that was just a
an absolute disaster
he played a move i'd never seen before
and he rocked me he
had me against the against the lockers
in the football room there i mean i was
getting blasted with all these moves i'd
never seen
i i i you managed to make really
interesting analogies of
everything that happens in chess so
you'll always have that talent um
charlie what about it in the last game
it seemed like you were winning
and then when you got into time pressure
can you explain your
your knight f6 move um
in oh where i threw it at his uh his
bishop
yeah uh i thought i saw a way of winning
the queen
i thought because in the last game i
pinned the bishop and in this game
for some reason i thought the bishop was
still [ __ ] pinned for some reason
and it just didn't work at all
completely wrong with the positions on
the board
oh well it certainly happens i will say
though that your preparation in the
opening was phenomenal
rain what did you think of his opening
place so obviously he studied kind of
how
um yeah i was been playing and that was
a really nasty trap
that some gm worked on with you who
taught you that
that was daniel naraditsky the prophet
yeah yeah and i fell right for it and i
knew i was like you know there's a trap
in here i'm being trapped
and i was like i'm not quite sure what
to do
so i should have um i should have pushed
that other
that other pawn what is that e pawn
um yeah sorry i'm bringing up bringing
up the position here
yeah it was a really sweet trap and i
was like ah
[ __ ] and i couldn't get my balance after
that i just couldn't get the game i
wanted to play after that
so yeah i mean i'll take it getting a
draw against you is just as good as
getting a dubski against pretty much
anyone else in the tournament so i'm
happy with that i'm not you're
and you're no no man that's that's so
not true
well i'm digging this i'm digging the
hair that i am digging this
this look thank you you are going to be
going up against
benji fishy in the semifinals he's been
one of the top performers
i think he's second by raiding right now
how do you feel your chances are
especially with your new hairstyle
well the hair the hair won't let me down
if i'm the new chest jesus
but um uh i don't know i haven't looked
at his games honestly i need to um
kind of look at at his style of play and
and get a little
get a little prepped there so i don't
know i
am in a lot of ways you know i'm just my
own worst enemy
in this i don't know if you feel that
same way critical because i
just my nerves and i and then the nerves
and i can't
quite think straight i can't kind of
really think the way that i normally do
in like a 10 minute game on chess.com
where i'm kind of
way more like detached and analytical
and i'm able to kind of
see patterns a little better i'm just
kind of like
i stumble in a little sometimes i
impulsively move
when i shouldn't even though i'm not
under any kind of time rush i got six
minutes on the
clock and i'm like you know and just oh
yeah um
so i'm kind of my own worst enemy so i
want to just get
and this is a good good um this is good
character building
it looks so calm though when you're
playing me and alex are saying that that
you
really look rock solid throughout the
whole game this is your thinking
technique you always put it right in the
middle between your two nostrils is this
some kind of secret
or what is this i actually have a third
nostril
that i secretly pick on camera
that's that's wonderful teeny tiny third
nostril filled with boogers
that is the secret to your success and
speaking of success
critical you've had huge improvement i
know it's the end of the road for you
in this pog champs three but you've made
huge
progress since your first one is chess a
game you're gonna continue playing maybe
we'll see you in pogchamps four
no i quit rain wilson ruined it for me
christmas is over i'm done no
it's the end oh no
okay i guess there's a new chest jesus
in town he's taking he's taking the mojo
do you want to be do you want to be do
you want to be chess buddies critical
yeah i'd like that yeah if rayne's gonna
take me under his wing i'll stay
we can play and like hold hands perfect
this has been a very amicable uh end to
the match thank you so much rain wilson
and critical
um rain good luck in your match against
benji and
critical congrats again for your huge
progress hey thank you i appreciate it
it's always fun i hope you uh win the
tournament range that way i could at
least say i lost to the winner of the
whole thing
i'll do my best thanks thanks guys
thanks for having me awesome thanks
everyone
thank you all right well
that was very wholesome i feel like
critical is bros with almost everyone
he's a
very hard person to not be friends with
up next we are going to see nico versus
rubius
two spanish speaking streamers who are
very close in rating they're going to be
battling it out to see who moves on to
the quarter
to the semifinals of the consolation
bracket and uh
anna anything you're looking forward to
in that match
i'm looking forward to everything in
that match it's going to be an
epic match to follow and i'm super
excited to see
two spanish-speaking streamers as i'm
half spanish as well
oh awesome maybe you can interview them
in spanish then
that would be super fun well let's take
a look at the championship bracket now
because we
do have one of the semi-finals
already finalized so we see that it's
going to be benji fishy playing against
rayne wilson later today we're going to
see ludwig versus logic the winner of
which is going to go against sardoche we
are getting very close
to figuring out who is going to be
crowned the champion
of pogchamps 3. uh with that being said
we have to thank somebody else who has
also been one of our
champions and that is guayaki
we want to take a moment thank you for
supporting pogchamps this year
as guayaquil liberates 25 years of
regenerative
yerba mate they're sharing cases to
celebrate
spam the guayaki emote in chat for your
chance
to win you're going to win something
very exciting if you do it so go for it
spam it in the chat
and we will be back after the break
start the next match
one pillow
we have the portuguese uh gambit right
with knight f6 here to hit the pawn on
d5
yeah but do do they know it's the
portuguese gambit is really the question
is this preparation or is this just
a little bit of inspiration over the
board because um
it must be this must be i don't mind
it's
fine let's not overthink it
yeah if we go up middle we both trade
i lose a little bit based on development
but that's the opening that he chose so
it's no problem
uh i think you were right it looks like
prep it looks like he
set out to play the portuguese gambit to
attack felix's queen
yeah and it makes sense i think
certainly he is the underdog um so i i
do like the idea of trying to go for
something early again
i felt that in all the matches where the
players sort of the stronger players um
outshine their opponents was in the
middle game or the end game
when when it got deeper and deeper into
the game and they just they weren't able
to
come up with the concepts as easily so i
think the opening phase is the most
important phase
um for the weaker players with players
who are perceived to be the weaker
players in terms of the uh the match
match setup for rubios it's very tricky
too because the ideas here are not
obvious h5 and f5 don't seem very
logical
based if you're just if you're just
getting um getting used to uh getting
getting used to chess so it seems like
moves that are not not so
so common in a sense at the same time
you've done all the basics you've
developed and you've gotten your king
out knight before however
is not a move that i would have played
now i'm a little bit concerned
if xqc castles the king here i think
he's actually quite a bit better
having said that knight takes c2 would
completely explode the position because
he'll also win the d3 pawn
so something like this this and then
bishop takes
and then xqc is not going to be able to
castle short
yeah so then then i don't know man then
i don't know what's going to get me
it goes e4 wow so i think x
x q c will probably take the knight here
as my guess because he'll see that pawn
takes his bad
because he's going to be worried about
these tactics on uh with the pawn next
to his queen and the fork ideas
so i think he probably will take the
knight here check
all right take
he's calculating i can take rock and
push
if i take only looking at this deep one
right now if i take
take
i'll take queen takes
i don't think he's realizing he actually
can take that knight and then take back
on f3
pushing his better oh okay nice
i'm this is this is very annoying this
is very annoying the thing at the right
place stop i actually stopped dude so
let's analyze why
specifically the move d4 led to such a
massive drop off it's because when pawn
takes f3 happen cicara i'm assuming
you can no longer take the knight
because g2 correct
but again he takes on f3 i mean so far
everything rubius has done has been very
very impressive
xc has to take with the bishop i feel
like xc is a little bit nervous
actually it seems like he's nervous and
he's not really sure of himself in the
way that he needs to be
um because some of these moves like d4
are very very unusual
from him oh well hikara this was
expected after yesterday
but we've just crossed a hundred
thousand viewer threshold we're at a
hundred and one thousand viewers so
shout out to each and every one of you
shout out to each and every one of you
so much love thank you all for being
here
wow this is crazy what we're seeing so
far i mean
in terms of the audience it's amazing in
terms of the chess this is uh this is
off to a very very bad start for xqc
that being said the one good thing
however is that the pawn on a7 is under
attack
that's the one good thing for x you see
here yes
so i think i mean again i think the
problem for xqc is he's also down on
time that's actually the biggest issue
that he has here
is not not even not even um the specific
position but the fact that he's down a
minute on the clock
however i do know when i when i was um
when i was doing stuff with with rubius
when we did the collaboration he was
also very slow and when he got low on
time
he was also panicking a little bit so if
rubius is not able to keep this big time
advantage
um i could see i could see uh
potentially some nerves and and get
getting worried
um also oh we've wondered [ __ ] five oh
boy
oh wow oh oh
oh was that a oh was that a slip or it's
just
just
a slip i don't think he intended i i
don't think
the xqc's got to just chill out for a
second not too long because he only has
a minute and five seconds
get his rook to safety and pushes other
pawns right
i mean again this is a very hard
position i think for both players to
play at this point
um the good thing for xc though is i
think it's he should i mean bishop g5 is
the move that i think he might play here
actually but
i don't i i wonder i think he's going to
go bishop g5 just to guess
oh my gosh that's such a stressful move
man
just a guess just again oh that's
probably wrong but it's just it's just a
guess
yeah you haven't been wrong yet so but i
oh my gosh actually he's got 30 seconds
he's also got to just move yeah
just just go as far away as possible
don't even think about it rook a7 keep
the king cut off
oh my god how did you know
i told you i didn't feel like this was
gonna happen
[Laughter]
are you kidding me
not the best move but it's okay
dude you're a genius
oh i [ __ ] up he's just gonna discover
does he have any discovery here no he
doesn't
i'm still good to go i could put that
bit away but i should just disengage
that rook d5 is a great move though
great move by rubius fantastic move
okay one minute don't stop music
sideways checkmates one
two three dunzo
come on you can swim over there if he
wants to ride
he can go to the right if he wants to
you saw the one square
check
this is so epic
there's no stylemates here at least
right there's well there is one queen e6
is the only style mate
hikaru stop stop it stop it
he's done it yes wow
yes baby are we going to go to the game
you know what oh
wow oh
see early game you don't do that it's a
big mistake that that's
terrible see what i did there good job
good job you you have him on the ropes
you got him on the [ __ ] ropes one
more one more to go
he cut all that hair off he lost all the
brain juice good [ __ ] job
good [ __ ] joke let's go let's go okay
one more one more
i mean yes made no real mistakes pretty
much picture perfect so
i think we've been underestimating um
underestimating rubius i think it's
going to be interesting to see because
i'm
very concerned uh xqc's openings with
black he's playing the petra off again
he's played this many many times with
some very
poor results so it's it it's quite scary
to see this opening occurring again
and yeah like i was saying what's amazed
me so far is how well all the players
have done like
in the previous two editions there were
always moments where you you felt like
certain players were really
mismatched and kind of very early on in
the game you felt like it was just like
okay well unfortunately for the players
weaker they're just
you know they're not as strong they're
going to lose and it seems like in this
event
every time every match has been really
close the openings have been very
balanced um
and it's just great to see really really
great to see so far
everything he said is exactly how you're
supposed to approach a thought process
in chess
he played his idea saw what his opponent
could do
worked it out and said it's good he
evaluated it and look it's happening
d5 there it is he predicted it i also
thought i just looked up at this
he was trying to impersonate me or
something i saw him just look up at the
sky and start pointing every which way
so
i did just notice and do that i'm not
sure i'm not sure what exactly was going
on but i did i did see that
well he inspires you and you inspire him
right back it's a
it's a beautiful it's a beautiful
relationship he's got to go to the
middle right
he's gotta the danger though is we saw
him arrowing towards a5 and c4 on the
very edge of the board so that's the one
danger here
um if he puts a knight in the center i
think he's doing well if he goes the
other way i
i'm quite concerned um wow he does it
he does it yeah it's it's very hard to
under to figure out the attacking ideas
um xuc is using a lot of timing oh
no oh no oh no terrible move
oh no and you know it's actually a
terrible
oh but you know what i realized i think
pawn takes pawn was a better move
not objectively but i think for
attacking ideas it was a better move
than this
because now after xcc moves his queen um
it's at least his king is safe still
fine it's fine we lost this fine did it
earlier we'll do it again
ow did you hear that hikara
he just said we were minus three we'll
do it again just like you you guys are
completely in sync today like
but he is analyzing it now
[ __ ] it's okay
i overthought it that's what happened
i think that's one of the best moves
good defense that's a great
move wow
yeah let's pull that up if
if xqc doesn't realize that knight takes
d6 as a threat
it could be all over okay and he's taken
now we got to get queen takes yeah
rubies will take with the queen for sure
i don't think there's any question about
that
i don't really see how xcc is going to
survive this though because i feel like
now it's shifted the other way where
basically white is the one who has the
easy moves
like you can move the rook down the pawn
on d6 is also very weak
um and xcc doesn't really have any kind
of attack uh towards the white king so i
i don't really know how he's going to
pull this one out i think most likely
ruby is going to win this game
it is really hurting actually he finds
queen b2 very nice move
yeah he finds queen b2 linking up the
queen in the rook and
it's how is it even
how is it even m11 is it like queen
takes b1
i think the computer is just crazy or no
because you can go king d7 somehow
and then survive right you sack the rook
and then yeah he's got to play queen
but what a comeback huge
yeah i think rubius has been putting in
a lot of work offshore as well as the
sense i get because he's playing this
very very well i mean once once he uh
once he
once he's got that extra bishop again
just very very good
and now no mouse slip by ruby it's just
queen b8 instead of queen b7
and um and that's game over and i expect
him to find it
yeah i i think he's just taking his time
because he has it i think last game he
blundered the bishop
right exactly yeah
he's maybe we can check in on his stream
to see the celebration right before
or as it happens
i don't know if we're going to be able
to do that but he is drawing an arrow to
b7 he's actually not even
oh no oh no
very tense he hasn't drawn it to b8
oh my gosh he got all the way there
in fact he should remove the arrow so he
sees that he can go the full length it
might just be like true
that's true he might be hindering his
own vision here oh my gosh
oh my gosh he might have this is crazy
he stopped to be
oh he's going the other way
oh no he missed it
all right let's pull this back up and
that is actually why
arrows help but you gotta be able to
remove them also left click on any empty
square that you can't move to or
oh man wow and now the xcc finds bishop
to g7 it's game on again bishop g7 and
he finds it and now it's
now it's uh it's game on again this is
unbelievable
he has no check positions here with his
screen whoa
i haven't heard him say it yet all this
power on the right side
all the right side power is so yeah he's
got plus one on pawns but who cares
that is unbelievable actually by the way
you know what's funny lovey it still
says mate in 14.
not so much how i don't know it says
14 for white i i really don't know
either but it's pretty funny
he can't do that yes he needs to go
upwards i mean mind you it's that's not
gonna happen because it's it's game off
where can he go i see
here that's insane
oh my gosh wait what
queen takes excuse he can't believe it
and you know it's still not over
yeah it's still not over but i mean i
think again it's
oh i see it wow good move i
take he checks
what what
boss man just take the bishop doesn't
matter
it's like the damn bishop
i'm good
oh he chucks i block he takes i take it
she checks i blocky ticks i take it
i need to get rid of that crossfire
though asap
all right he's playing really well
king d6 and there it is it's gone
now let's see if rubios can play rook a7
and get winning chances again or not
winning chance but try to create some
some sort of idea to keep it complicated
oh and rubius ah
yeah next uc is converting it seamlessly
and he's he's he's getting amped up
fine he can still go to the right
and we can discover him think about it
wouldn't
lean
very nice wow
wow amazing
dad let's go baby
i i didn't want to expect anything you
know uh coming out of your opponents i
just
i just played my game right so my plan
was just to play my game and not like
think about his rating or his projected
skill whatever
and um all of his openers i know how to
transition from from early game to mid
game
and i all my pieces were all scattered
and stuck in in blocks
and it opened up tons of good moves from
and i was lost like
i didn't know what to do how to move and
um you know
i i couldn't breathe the whole time i
was only playing his game
and i was never playing my game and uh
that stressed me out
i'll i think i only won because um he
made mistakes
later on in his game right because i
never got to play mine
so i'm happy about the wins i'm like i'm
happy but
um i think i could have done so much
better so at the beginning it was uh
i felt like i was ahead of him like i
had many more pieces than him
at the beginning or at the mid match but
at the late game i always screw up
because i get
like confident overconfident and then i
start making mistakes
and so yeah i think that happened in
both of the matches like
in the beginning uh uh i was like a
little bit ahead but then at the end it
was like boom
so but it was really fun like like we
were saying uh aft
before we did like many mistakes both of
us like i did a
pega move he did a pepeka move and then
he did a genius move and then
i do a normal move a good mood so yeah
it was like i felt it was like he was
saying like real chess so i enjoyed it
really much
i started playing like uh three months
ago or something like that like
and it was also not because of queen's
gambit but it was uh because
the the previous pog times where xqc
failed in six moves after that i began
watching more more test streams and it
was thanks to
xqc and hikaru so yeah sweet
i don't remember that six moves i don't
know what you're talking about i'm not
sure i like the
like the variational approach here
no please don't and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
yeah with moisture critical it was
amazing
oh yeah um
[Music]
okay his opponent is not playing very
well either
trade queens nope there is a bishop
i mean he's just moving the pieces he's
literally just moving the pieces
blunder's a bishop
another bishop blunder's a night
and a night and he loses on time and
um let's see let's check out another one
here's another loss let's see
here's a 10 minute game that he played
here's a 10 minute game that he played
charlie right on
that's really sweet here's a 10 minute
game
yeah i mean
yeah no he did a lot of puzzles actually
so he sees some stuff here but by and
large
just blunders on every move basically
and
yeah i mean it's crazy i mean the
the difference between that and now so
yeah we can celebrate how far he's come
300 bits from goblin thank you
and yeah i think nerves nerves were the
main reason honestly that was that was
really the only thing
the proximal cause anyways guys
um that was great obviously pock champs
goes on
there's more games and uh i'll i'll
definitely be
be watching them at some point um right
now
i don't have too much time left to
stream
he wants to hit 1250 next month no
absolutely he will
i think with the right kind of training
he will definitely definitely has the
skill
um so i'm on chest tv yeah welcome
everybody thank you thank you
of course no it's more than
understandable more than understandable
um maybe i'll play a couple of blitz
games myself let's see if anybody's
online
to play blitz with wow
um okay maybe i'll play some 30 second
chests yeah that might
be a that might be a pretty good
use of time just to de-stress a little
bit
all right i'll challenge some people in
30-second chess
of course now i'll lose now that i'm
like in front of a hundred thousand
people
thank you for the 10 bucks babe
appreciate it thanks thanks for the kind
message all right we got a 30 second
game going
we got a 30 second game going
yeah he's my opponent's also lagging a
little bit
all right
let's go here double stack the rooks
right h6 95 is gonna
knight you for gonna swing the knight
around to e3
my opponent is good he's a very good
bullet player
he is a very good bullet player
very fast young young player i'm old
he's young so you know you know how it
is
all right i think i'm going to win this
game
we're going to push this pawn forward
push the spun promote promote to a queen
get our queen in d5 and
this is going to be a checkmate
no that i definitely do have competition
for ruja is somebody who can compete
with compete with me in 30 seconds and
tang they're actually better than me
in 32nd 100 bids from hectas thank you
appreciate all the hype guys
um okay let me think about how i want to
structure this for a second
uh i need to run to the bathroom guys am
i still on chess tv if so i will
continue to play
i have about 30 more minutes um so
we will do i'm still on chesapeake okay
so we'll play one more then
um let's see yeah i mean five minutes
left okay okay let's play some more 30
second then
oh i might do one speed run game and
then whoa curious chimpanzee
five gifted subs damn girl thank you
thank you
really really appreciate it i'll be on
trustee forever that's right
because i'm the most entertaining
streamer
okay let's um let's see
let's play one more 30 second game you
guys can challenge me if he wants 30
second
i should plug something i don't know
i'm not a plugger
get ready all right here we go
the car in 30 seconds oh oh cara is
playing the 30 second chest
okay i i i realized that was too good to
be true thank you taiko right or roman
guard
okay he aborted okay fine i'll we'll
play unrated
maybe he wants unrated moist wow charlie
with a with a huge rating 173
thank you so much charlie i really
really appreciate
that um it's sub only yeah let's
disenable sub
only we got tons of subs anyway
he doesn't want 30 seconds um okay uh
well how about bullet then
bullet is fine with me okay blitz
bullet yeah bullet okay oh he wants
blitz okay okay fine
okay thank you so much shirley that was
a phenomenal performance uh this has
been a pleasure and
you will reach great heights my man so
thank you sir all right
so let's go d6 here
and now let me un enable the alerts
thank you so you want to
playing a couple games of the car right
here well then whoops well the next game
starts
all right i have been in a pretty bad
slump
lately uh blitz wise myself
whoa ghostgirl44 thank you so much ghost
girl 44 for five gifted
i appreciate it this is phenomenal stuff
appreciate it ghost girl
fantastic business here
okay i um no i definitely have been uh
been playing badly and it happens you
know that's why i'm in no position to
give charlie any kind of smack for for
anything because
part of a part of being a good player
and
is being in for the long haul and
sometimes you just
things don't add up your brain doesn't
work the way that it should
and stuff you know
woke up
[Music]
so he attacks my pawn
hmm yeah this is not not easy to find a
move here actually
i guess we can go v6
all right
i mean it is true that i i should be
higher rated right now
i'm not usually below 3 000 hence
it's fair to be somewhat disconcerted
about it
no is that so far crips
welcome welcome let's go here
i blended this yeah i'm just blundering
stuff left and right
unfortunately this is only a pawn though
it's not the end of the world
let's go knight c5 i guess we can take
here but then he takes there
it's not good
let's go back
all right well nothing is easy three
thousand no
usually it's not it's not a thing
all right 96.
so then i want to go bishop c7
d8
and back to f8
okay then maybe c5 and
yeah this is this is looking pretty damn
grim
oh nightstand got it oh i now i
understood before cribs
it takes me a while to understand those
things you know
[Music]
okay for whatever
hmm i guess i can sack a second pawn
here to open the diagonal
oh yeah this is completely lost yeah
bishop g7 even
g7 is easy
all right let's take it
yeah after that blender in the opening
all right let's take it unite back to g5
yeah let's try to get a revenge in the
next game
introducing the grip 6 belt the only
belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip 6 is so
light and thin that you'll barely even
notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes
this belt the most comfortable belt in
the world
overly confident much you're damn right
because on top of being the most
comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear
and damn tee
meaning if you don't like any belt for
any reason at any time or in any
condition
you can just contact us and we'll give
you a full refund
rip six is still doing their pog champs
giveaway
so go to go.chess.com grip6 to enter now
they're drawing a name for a premium
chess set
today so you guys know that's a 300
value make sure you're entered to be
eligible for that and other future
giveaways
use code pogchamps 20 for 20 all
items um i'm really looking forward to
trying those belts out i actually have
one of them as well
in my closet but let's talk a little bit
about the community outreach that
chess.com is doing
chess.com is matching up to a hundred
thousand dollars of viewer donations
during this event
the donations will be given to the
participants preferred
non-profit organizations and you can
look that
depending on how they do in the
championship bracket in the consolation
bracket
that is going to influence how much
money they're able to donate to their
charity of choice
so far we have almost nineteen thousand
dollars in viewer charity donations
um hopefully we can get to twenty five
thousand uh very soon
let's take a look at the participants
and see which charities they picked
uh anna you were you were telling me
that you recognized no kid hungry in
unicef i know you've done a lot of
charity events in the past as well which
charities have you partnered with and
well
the actually the only one that i did
is the one that i did with you alex a
long time ago oh that's awesome for
for us women's chest and getting more
girls into the game
exactly yes yes yes exactly so that was
a lot of fun when we played hand and
brain together
and that was it was not the first time
that i did a collab with you but
i think it was the second time it was
right when i started streaming so now i
remember
yeah the good old days they get all day
so yeah that was
that was a while ago but i would
definitely definitely love to be doing
some more charity events because it's
such an important cause and i mean
the fact that you know we can we can and
that we have an outreach to so
so many different people i mean i think
it's great to um
to just just bring charities here and to
just
like uh yeah to just make
or to just like show the importance of
charities and should just work for
charities because we have the
opportunity to do so
so yeah what charities have you worked
with alex
um i've been working with care which is
one of the
uh older humanitarian organizations and
they help people
in over 150 countries and around the
world so that's
been who i've worked with for the last
two times but
we're actually doing another charity
stream uh this friday for people
in texas who are affected by the power
outage so i'm looking forward to that
but um i'm really proud that everybody
was able to do some research
sardoch still has tba and he's actually
one of the favorites but i'm sure that
he will have his charity listed there as
well so thank you again to everybody who
has
donated so far let's take a look at the
championship
bracket we just got a donation from
norder for 12.15
thank you so much in order we really
appreciate it that's amazing thank you
so this morning we saw rain wilson take
down moist critical
he is going to be going up against benji
fishy
both of these players have been playing
incredibly well
benji fishy is coached by grand master
han
hammer a super grand master he's been
improving very quickly too because
benji has been playing chess every
single day who do you think the favorite
is in that matchup
it's a great question but i mean i have
to say i'm so impressed with how benji
has been playing
and i saw that the last three games he
played he actually played with over
90 accuracy which is just
incredible especially because even
though he's been playing quite a lot
uh these past months he didn't really
play a lot of chess before that so
it's amazing to see how how much
uh how much he's improved during this
park champs time and
i'm proud to say that i had one little
coaching session with him but
all the credit goes to hammer that's
awesome and i will say it does seem a
little bit like a battle of young versus
old benji is one of the youngest
participants he is 17.
it it would be really funny if they
dress similar so it'd look like
it's uh his younger self playing against
his older self
that would actually become that would
actually be hilarious they should
definitely outfit match for that
imagine that imagine that um i mean i
feel like you know rain he came up today
with
with uh the jesus costume i'm sure that
he'll come up with something against
benjy fishy as well
yeah for sure and later today we are
gonna see ludwig versus logic
very very close in raiding and the
winner will be going up against
sardoche so let's take a look as well at
the consolation bracket
um we've talked a lot about nico and
rubius who are going to be playing
but the other match that's going to be
happening today is pokemane versus myth
and myth actually tweeted a photo where
he defeated pokeman's bot and he said
just a preview for tomorrow
the trash talk is on who do you think is
a favorite in this match anna
wow wow wow well
i have to say that i'm very impressed
with pokemane i said it before and i'm
going to say it again i'm very impressed
with how well
she's playing and how much she's
improved uh this past month so i'm gonna
say pokeman but
i think it's gonna be a really close and
exciting match yeah she has been
improving so much and we saw that in her
game against rubius where she was the
underdog and she
beat him twice even declining one of his
draws she wanted a perfect score so
pokemane is no joke and i've been very
impressed to see
how quickly she picks up chess very
similar to other games she picks up
yup i think it's so cool i mean like
yeah me alex we've been playing chess
for a long time but these people just
started playing chess and they're
picking it up so quickly i'm really
impressed and i think it's
so amazing to see that absolutely well
let's take a look at the schedule for
today um
so we saw the first game it ended in one
and a half
zero and a half in rain wilson's favor
critical did have chances to win the
game
but ended up getting a draw after
he you know had a couple blunders in
there that being said
he had a nice session with his coach
grandmaster nero diski after and
he did say he will indeed continue
playing chess so hopefully we'll see him
in a future pog champs
and you know what rain is gonna keep on
going um we talked a lot about nico and
rubius they're gonna be starting very
shortly
and then we're gonna swap with hikaru
and levy who are gonna be commentating
the second half
ludwig versus logic and pokemane versus
myth
that being said let me remind you guys
also about something a little bit
different in the schedule which is going
to be happening this
thursday february 25th it's going to be
the match between tubo and code miko
there's only going to be one match on
this day this is going to be
to figure out who makes it to the
semifinals of the consolation bracket
also thank you guys so much for that
last donation we really appreciate it
and we are getting closer and closer to
the charity goal
um anna do you see yourself doing any
charity streams in the future
definitely i really do and it's
something that i think it's so important
and just like i said before knowing that
uh
you know me and my community could help
out
to charity it's it's just amazing to to
know that and it's something that i
definitely want to do very soon so
hopefully i'll be able to do that soon
absolutely
well you guys this is pogchamps 3
brought to you by grip6 we will be right
back
with the match between rubius and nico
so don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
let me know
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nosotros
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
a
[Music]
they're not ready
[Applause]
oh and we're ready life
down time is life i'll face life
smashing boys like yeah and we get it
like
and my dog's like and it sounds like
all day long all night life all day long
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
is
i am
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
is
joshua
a
[Music]
is
[Music]
paraguay
okay so this is a message for the people
in the chess.com stream okay here you go
oh my god
rubios
and rubios
rubies
did you know you can subscribe to his
twitch channel for free
if you link your amazon account with
your twitch account
what you didn't know
are you a blood
please subscribe to lruvius on twitch
right now bug in the chat
boys
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
everyone we're back welcome to pog jams
three presented by grip6
hopefully you guys have been enjoying
watching rubio honestly
i took notes when i saw the way he asked
for twitch primes what did you think of
that zulu announcement anna
i think that was really funny and
probably pretty effective as well that
was hilarious
anna do you ask for for primes in your
community
i actually don't um yeah i actually
don't
i don't i just feel like it doesn't
really fit with my personality but
um i mean everybody does it their own
way right and i always feel a little bit
weird asking too but i you know
all the twitch people do it and maybe if
i had a pre-recorded video
like rubius does maybe i should just
yoink it from him and use that in our
channel instead
maybe maybe maybe that's the trick and
also then you'll be pre-recorded you
wouldn't have to like
actually be be saying it live you know
yeah absolutely well okay
it looks like we actually have the
players ready which is super exciting
um yeah let me just fix the board this
is not the
critical and rain game um we got
nico and rubius i know that uh nico had
a little bit of
internet connectivity issues but she is
here she's ready to go
do you think that sometimes when you're
rushed you
play a little bit worse oh yeah yeah
definitely definitely definitely
also i can feel like if i'm rushed
before i before one of my streams which
a lot of times i am a bit rushed before
the first three games that i play
they're just going to be horrible
right that's what i feel like when i
play title tuesday and i come in late
and i'm there right 10 seconds before it
starts i'm not able to calm down my
nerves and just focus on the
the chest right away i want to play you
on title tuesday sometime that would be
super fun alex
yeah that would be great um we should
just go and try to scalp the
you know items and gm's i think we
should we should take some for the wfm
team
i think we should yeah i think we should
almost team up you know yeah
exactly oh okay nico looked a little bit
out of breath i hope she wasn't running
to get here she has been playing
so well and i think she has great
chances in the consolation bracket
meanwhile rubius has been listening to
motivational videos
somebody told him to drink some egg
yolks rocky style but
uh i don't i don't think he he listened
to that advice have you ever drank
egg yolks i have not but yeah they've
definitely had different preparation i
hope that niko just like you said didn't
have to run too much
as rubius really has taken his time to
hype himself up
and i think it's great that he was
listening to these motivational videos i
think i thought they were really
inspiring
yeah i actually like listening to
motivational videos especially when i
work out because
you know i just want to walk i don't
want to run but they really helped give
me that extra boost so i'm guessing they
did for rubius as well
i think so he does look really ready for
this match
yeah he he definitely does um
i would feel a little bit bad if he
doesn't get any wins this tournament he
hasn't scored a point
yet how do you feel that's affecting his
psychology
i think that obviously it's kind of
tough to
get into a match knowing that you
haven't played or that you haven't won a
single game before
but at the same time it seems like he's
taking it really well and that he's
having a really fun time
so i don't think he's taking it too hard
to be honest
yeah absolutely and i mean you know he's
one of the biggest streamers on the
entire platform
he's a professional he's been through
all the ups and downs so i feel like he
makes great content regardless and it's
really really impressive to see what
he's able to do
definitely it can be hard sometimes when
you're you know when you're kind of sad
about
playing badly or in any game i guess and
if you lose that it's it can be kind of
hard to still be happy and hyped up but
i think he does it in a great way and
just like you said he's an amazing
content creator
yeah absolutely and he's also had some
really tough pairings so i'm not trying
to
you know say that it's been because of
his chess pokemane i know
really prepared for him and she was one
of the lower rated opponents he had xqc
has been playing in pogchamps one and
pogchamps too so that was difficult
danielle negranu had some experience
with chess so he has been a little bit
fed to the wolves
yup he's definitely played against
really strong players and
he is still up to up to a really strong
player today as well nico
has been playing some great chess and
just like you said before she drew
against our dodge
so she's been playing really well and
even though she's a bit lower rated
i really think that this is going to be
a very exciting match yeah and i'm just
making sure that we're following the
right people
because i don't see the game yet and you
know
chat loves debating the commentators we
are following nico yeah the game just
hasn't started you guys
i love to see that everybody's really
excited though
that's amazing just like it should be
tell us in the chat
who you think is going to be the winner
of this match yeah let's let's see some
predictions over here i did get debated
congratulations pepes you got me niko
just gave the thumbs up she looks like
she is ready to get into it nico of
course
is a tick tock sensation she's also a
streamer
she's also signed with 100 thieves both
of these two content creators are super
talented and i'm sure they'll put on a
great show once they're started
which they just got niko 863
versus rubius 875. rubius is playing
from andorra
it is certainly his tax haven which is
really funny because he's so
famous and his wikipedia is you know
maybe like three sentences for the first
description of him and it just talks
about how he moved to andorra for tax
purposes
i know i loved it i'm like i'm really
like very notable
why are people calling him out like that
let the man live okay
he's one of the biggest conte creators
in the whole internet oh yeah
the biggest sensation yeah and he's
donating to tva right so
i don't know he's a smart financial guy
very shrewd let's see how that
impacts his chest no i'm totally joking
you guys
so nico is starting again with her bird
opening but h3
is not theory i think she's just very
afraid of this
pin uh how how much of an inaccuracy
would you call h3
i'm just scared about the dark squares
this uh
queen h4 i mean obviously if the queen
cannot go to h4 right now because
there's a knight on f3 but
let's say that black would play
something like e5 and
white white would would take then there
might be
um e5 pawn takes knight takes knight
takes
and if you can put that up but then
there would be a queen age for checkmate
there
so drawing arrows for for your plan uh
awesome yeah so yeah so i'm kind of
scared about stuff like that but he
played e6 instead
and i mean there's nothing wrong with
that he's trying to get his dark square
bishop out
so his bishop is going to be able to
develop pretty quickly i will say he
isn't taking advantage
of the inaccuracies in nico's opening
but i think that's very normal
it's super hard to do that in a 10
minute game when you're around 800
and oh my gosh nico is being
very bold with g4 do you think
this is going to pay off or is she going
to weaken her king side
i mean i just gotta say kudos to nico
for for
having these internet issues running in
here and then just going h3 g4 i think
that's awesome
that she's playing so aggressively she's
ready yeah i mean
i with this play it's like one of those
assassins who just comes in and gets the
job done
and gets out look at that pure face of
focus
actually they both look very focused
almost like they're having a stare wait
are they trying to do the same thing
they're pretty much doing the same thing
that's a really typical standard
what's your post alex when you're
playing chess um i
i think i put my my head in my hands
like this it's just very comfortable you
know
let me try it out actually what's your
pose
i always sit like like this i just like
put my hands like this and i just
kind of you know get into my little zone
wait a second wait a second what just
happened oh yeah nico just blundered a
piece i'm so sorry to cut you off there
i just didn't want to miss the action
because
if rubius sees knight takes f3 then he
can take the bishop on f4 and he'll be
up an entire piece
that's a full piece there wow i
completely missed that when i was doing
my little pose there
yeah no no worries i i was the one who
asked you to let's take a listen in
on rubius and see if he's calculating
this
no
seeing that there are these uh these
x-rays that you know the bishop is
hanging out
oh my gosh he saw it good job
i love it we have our local translator
here anna kremling anna how many
languages do you speak
spanish english swedish um
i tried taking french in school but that
didn't go so well i also studied chinese
for a couple years but
i can't speak chinese but well that's
awesome that's awesome we're lucky we
have such a multi-talented host here
today
okay so both sides castled and rubius is
just
up a full piece nico is playing really
quickly i truly think that she must have
just been a little bit rattled
with uh you know being ready for a
tournament and
having some internet connectivity issues
because otherwise i don't think she
would have played so fast
no i totally agree with you i've seen in
general though that she plays pretty
fast for games
but yeah she's playing super fast right
now she
she is three minutes up basically uh
[Music]
expression right now reminds me of when
i would coach
kids whose parents were forcing them to
be there i know that's not the case
it's just the intense look but for a
moment there i couldn't tell between
intensity and boredom i'm sure it's just
the intensity
yeah it can be hard to distinguish those
two but
um i i think it's really cool how we all
you know doesn't matter who you are
every chess player kind of looks the
same when you're playing yeah exactly
exactly
um and rubius has a kind of
bold idea maybe queen d6 and he could
try to take advantage of the fact that
nico's pawns on her king size king side
have really been pushed
um yeah absolutely i mean g4 was kind of
aggressive but i think it also might
have been way too early to play that
especially if she castled king side
but i mean one thing if she castled
queen side but now the king is getting
very weak and we can set the pawn on h3
is also hanging
after rubius moves his knight right and
she is playing very very quickly
still g5 maybe she's trying to get the
d5 pawn
i like that she's going for those kind
of bold and crazy moves because
she's down a piece here so that might
give her a chance
um if the queen ends up taking on g5
her king is in trouble but she can run
to h1 and maybe bring the rook to g1
yeah she could do something like that an
open g-file even though it looks like
the
white king is very weak and could also
lead to white perhaps having some
attacks
to the black king so placing your work
on g1 could definitely
put some pressure on the black king as
well but i really think that queen takes
g5
is probably the move to go for in this
position
just because the right is going to be
very weak and um
yeah there's also a bishop there on c7
oh no let's take a look at rubius
because he's hovering over bishop g3
which isn't a bad move
but i i hope that he doesn't miss that
he can take up the pawn with
marlene crusher
okay so he does play bishop g3 again not
a bad mood
just not the best food yeah exactly
exactly it is putting a pressure on the
rikoni one so
and he can probably take on g5 after
he's just gotta be a little bit careful
about the whole
uh pin to his rook on a8 we can see that
the bishop on f3 is sort of
looking at the rook on a8 there yeah
that's a great point and i just want to
give him a little bit of credit he did
notice that the knight was putting
pressure on his bishop
so he wanted to take care of that threat
and instead of playing super quickly
when he's up a piece
as you mentioned he's taking his time so
i'm very impressed with
his technique so far yep absolutely
absolutely it seems like he is trying to
have everything under control
even though he is a piece up right and i
i hope nico
slows down a little bit as well because
again she's had
great games in terms of over performing
her elo
so i think if she slows down a little
bit uh she'll make huge progress
yep i totally agree with you she just
needs to
to take a little think about every move
that she plays um
and now he's playing bishop b7 ooh
she does have some counter ideas she can
start something like rook g2
just to kick the bishop and put pressure
on the king and then maybe she can go
for some kind of discovery attack with
knight f6
putting pressure on the bishop and being
able to open up the file so
what really matters here is if in her
head she feels like she can come back
and she's going to try or if she feels a
little bit defeated because she
blundered that piece earlier on yep and
that's what we could see from the first
match when
uh with moe's critical that um because
he did feel a little bit defeated
perhaps
he didn't play the most active and best
moves all the time er just like you said
later but she went
king g2 instead of rick g2 right and
i understand that she's trying to kick
the bishop out of there unfortunately
the rook would have been a much stronger
choice because
now her king is still going to be able
to be checked after queen g5
so it is certainly going to get a lot
scarier for the white king here
yeah it definitely is it definitely is
especially because now
and the rook can never go to g2 to you
know kind of protect the king
so it's gonna get scary but rubios only
has four minutes left
he's getting very low on time and
i mean we're saying that niko is playing
fast but you know maybe i'll be to her
advantage at some point if ruby
gets really low on time yeah so let's
take a listen and see if he's noticing
the time situation at all
yeah he just wanted to bring his his
piece back he's not really talking about
the time but he's saying that he wants
to put pressure on the bottom
well that's good uh i wonder if he's
seen the g5 pawn
yet i haven't seen him arrow it no
those errors are awesome because with
those
speak of arrows devil there we go and
nico defends it good job for both of
them on finally notice
yeah we can really just
immediately see what the players are
thinking about without them saying the
words
oh and i love how chat has been spamming
spanish xqc and sometimes i also see
spanish pokemane i mean obviously they
are all big streamers and it's very cute
when chat you know
draws some similarities between
personalities
yeah absolutely i think so too i think
so too that's awesome
and rick b1 alright the bishop is
getting kicked out
and the bishop is coming back okay
he's putting pressure i will say that
her instinct
is to be very aggressive and she is
making moves
that are running down rubius's time
which is basically her main
idea here to try to survive and get
rubious law on time and maybe he'll
potentially blunder she still has that
pin you were talking about
are there any tricks rubius needs to be
careful about here
um well i think that one trick that ruiz
perhaps has to be a little bit
um worried about is if at some point
white could go
knight f6 check and i don't really think
that they can do that yet but the idea
of going knight f6 check is that the
bishop on b7
is unprotected at this point so if this
knight can move
um you know with some good check then
they could take on b7
but also for instance let's say that the
bishop would go now to b8
then there could be this knight e7 check
and then that would just be
uh uh a full piece for white because the
bishop on b7 would be unprotected and
no piece could take the knight on e7
that's a beautiful plan you just showed
i really love that because
him retreating his bishop of course
there's also bishop d6
but he just anna you are
explaining what's gonna happen in the
future is nico gonna see 97
oh she sees it right away the assassin
is here
for payday she is gonna take
the hit on rubius if she can look at
that she just played it immediately no
thinking nothing just
intuition sorry i was laughing at chat
because they put
x q with a little dash and then c like
yes in spanish that's very funny
chat you guys have a good sense of humor
i appreciate
everyone who's tuning in and watching
today y'all are awesome thanks so much
um okay so rubius now under two seconds
do you think nico's now the favorite to
win the game i think so
she has a clearly better position and
she also has seven minutes more time so
oh
why are the queens always gone you know
i
i i have flashbacks to losing my own
queen
and i do really find it painful to watch
queen blunders
you've been an inspiration alex yeah the
wrong kind
the wrong kind anna this is not the
legacy i
wish to leave
that's a full queen i mean wow
nico and that's a piece no i think he's
panicking
the time situation must be getting to
him uh he's now completely silent
and i also think the fact that he's had
really strong positions in previous
pogchamps game and ended up
you know having a little bit of a choke
maybe makes him scared
and i think it's really easy to tilt
when you've been putting yourself down
like that
yeah yeah absolutely i totally agree
with you and that's something that's
just like you said in many games in
pogchamps we've seen something similar
which is that
he has started with really great
positions i mean
almost out playing the opponent in some
of the games and just having this great
great
great positions but then he starts to
think a lot he's gotten down on time and
at some point he perhaps has blundered
so there's been a little theme
there certainly has been and nico is
just
seeing all the right moves now bishop c6
she can take and simplify i mean this
just looks like nico's game now
yup it does oh and oh no
ah you know i feel like when it rains it
pours
with rubius and when the sun's out it's
just the perfect day because he was
playing so well before it's like two
different rubiuses
yeah yeah definitely definitely it's
like day and night
yeah he seems to be let's listen in
let's listen in
what is he saying goodbye it's not
spanish
he doesn't have any piece defended
or maybe she's talking to her stream she
might also be live
yeah yep yeah i mean i i couldn't
exactly hear but
but yeah it looks like she's going to be
checkmating very soon as well queen of
fate
it's a very nice checklist oh well at
least she has a smile on her face it's
nice to see
how differently she's feeling now than
when she initially
got into the match good that was good
well happy oh rubius
not not so much but you know what he is
capable of playing very well
um i think he had one blunder and that
just was the first domino
to fall but ladies and gentlemen there
is
a second game will rubius be able to win
and come back in the tiebreaker or is
nico going to
go 2-0 against rubius having left rubius
with zero points in the entire
tournament
stay tuned to find out we'll be right
back after this break
it's been um myth has had myth has not
had chances
like myth in a couple of matches just
been over matched whereas i feel like
rubius he could have won any single one
of his games like literally he's had a
winning position
in every single one of the seven games
that he's that he's played um
oh why am i really he's had a winning
position in every single one of the
seven games
that he's played yeah so let me mute
this again all right let's go back here
so yeah he's had winning positions in
every single game i mean the main thing
with this uh
with this game that i would say is that
probably
uh what he did wrong was it was all very
good like this is
all great but then he tunnels like he
brought the bishop back and it was a
great idea
idea but he forgot that the reason was
to line up the battery here
with the bishop and the queen to go
towards the pawn in h2 this is what i
think he forgot like he had an idea that
he tunneled
and now after g5 it already gets very
dangerous because now you remove the
defender of the pawn and now the
diagonal opens up and even though black
is still completely winning
it gets very messy charlie lost earlier
yeah charlie lost a
very close match against rayne wilson
first game he kind of got blown out of
the water in a b3 ceiling
but second game he was winning out of
the opening he was up at night then he
was up with rook
then i think again he was up a rook
later and then then he uh the nerves got
the better of him unfortunately and
uh and he lost the game so really really
rough for um
for for for uh for for charlie very very
close
um so yeah jimmy's spiking it i know you
guys you guys were talking about
earlier i don't really want to look at
it super closely like i see amc is
spiking so i guess the reddit
the reddit trade is back again i mean i
i guess that's what it means
so i'll obviously be wasting time
looking at that um
as well but anyway uh i thought ludder
was gonna play
there more games going today more games
um so yeah thank you to quartzy for the
prime rush for the prime sugar for the
tier 1 thinking lanes
i'm going to do a few puzzles as well
let's let's go to puzzles um
let's go to puzzles we'll do a couple of
puzzles while we wait for the
next match this is black's plane once
you go
check me let me turn on sounds now one
second
make the queen check me collect the rook
with the pyramid of giza
uh check and meet um should be check
check mate king is stuck no squares
should be check and you gobble the rook
and then you gobble the juicer
now rookie four work b5 and take the
juicer
you make a queen and you win the game
you take and now you take the juicer
now you check you go for the the classic
corner corner triangle
you take you go check and it's me
because the king cannot escape here
so you go check rubius wants to be in
pogba chancellor yeah i mean ruby is
like i said
it's just maybe it's the nerves i don't
know what it is with rubius exactly
because he's had winning positions
against everyone
everybody he was winning in both his
games at one point he was winning
against xuc
both of his games against daniel negrano
who i think was one of the strongest
players in this event
he had winning positions in both of
those games too um
so like there were many chances for
rubius to win
for sure okay let's go
start go mate for three months rookie
one collect the juicer
a pawn goes off to let the world swallow
your morals
um you you're a great person you don't
seem like one to let the world swallow
your morals thank you viceroy stark they
need a crispy waffle saying to owl man
yeah i mean
i don't know if it's because i've it's
because i've been fortunate enough to
have a long career um playing over the
board or what it is exactly but yeah i
mean i'm not
what you see here is who i am in real
life you know to me like the notion of
like making sacrifice for like for like
viewership or you know trying to get
more clicks or these things like that's
just not me it never will be me
we're back with pogchamps three
presented by grip six
the very close rubius versus nico match
nico was able to get a win in the first
one we're gonna figure out if he's able
to come back
why is there drama you guys what drama
why is chad saying there's drama anna
are you in on this
i am not in on this i'm not i'm not
seeing it but
i i can be part of it i can check it out
well uh what's going on chad what's
going on chat you guys you know what
stop being drama frogs this is not
lsf this is chess this is a classy game
okay is alex is absolutely right it's a
classic game
let's listen in on rubyus figure out
what's going on here i'm a little
confused
he's saying that um yeah that
he feels like he's in a disadvantage
because he's streaming at the same time
oh cause he's distracted
i think so i think that's right that's
that's fair at the same time nico has
been streaming all of her matches today
was just
uh you know an unexpected loss of
internet and she did have to hurry there
so
hopefully he can get his head put on
i don't know what i was gonna say i
didn't want it to sound like a roast
calm his nerves down and play his best
game
absolutely i think that sounds great and
the game is starting e4 d6
there we go guys it's not excuse-y okay
excuses i man you guys are putting a lot
of tongue twisters in the chat all right
so
he's putting both of his pawns in the
center and nico is gonna play
um the pertz which is similar to what
rayne wilson played today so it's good
to see the pogchamps participants are
playing somewhat similar
openings here yup maybe she's got a
little bit of inspiration as well who
knows
maybe it's the other way around
absolutely and they're both
playing very quickly so rubius is in a
must-win situation otherwise he's
knocked out from the tournament but
everything is going great for both
players so far
it is it is it is and i think that rubio
has realized how important it is
to play fast it's kind of funny when i
say rubio's i go to like
spanish yeah yeah
but uh but yeah i think that he's
realizing that he needs to play really
fast this game
if he wants to have a chance to win yeah
for sure
although he doesn't have to play that
quickly he does need to speed up a
little bit
but whatever it's going to take to get
his confidence back where
where it needs to be that's the most
important thing yes he just needs to get
his confidence back
needs to stay focused and i think if he
does that
it's gonna go great he did play really
well uh before
all the dominoes started happening
exactly and i love how he's playing this
he moved rookie one which is a really
nice quiet move he's developed all of
his pieces
d4 is protected and nico also she's
clearly learned her
her systems here and uh it's good to see
that
she has a pretty solid black opening
because i think the bird with white was
um a little bit out there it was
it was h3 g4 that was very exciting to
watch
but yeah it was probably a little bit
too much but this seems to be a lot more
solid and now she's centralizing
her knight but it looks
for a second i thought um bishop e4
worked
but then there is bishop takes c3 so
maybe that is not the idea here
oh okay i said yeah if knight takes some
bishop takes there's this pin on the
pawn on e7 so you can take the pawn on
d6 maybe
but then the queen can recapture so
bishop takes e7 because there's a work
on e1 right and then
the rook and queen would be attacked
well that is a pretty wild tactic
um i don't expect rubius to see it that
being said
it is natural to just grab the knight
and then grab the pawn
what are the odds he sees that you think
oh let's listen in actually because he's
hovering
yeah let's see what he's thinking he
certainly is taking his time in a
critical position which is
the right time that could also work
actually
oh no nico just fell into the trap
she traded off the knight so now if she
recaptures on d6 we can go for that
tactic that you found bishop takes e7 is
ruby is gonna see
bishop takes e7 uh this this has to be
what he goes for but he's hovering over
the d-pawn right now he's highlighting
the night let's take another look in on
rubius because
this is a critical moment i want to see
if he sees that winning idea
yeah oh no
he places bishop on c4 and he does it he
goes bishop c4 and
immediately nico defends by going e6 and
now there's no more recapture on e7
well that is brutal but also kudos to
nico for fixing her mistake
the second she had a chance absolutely
immediately she did she didn't even
think a second she'd probably already
seen that
right for that he played g3 which is
going to weaken his king position for
sure i have
noticed that um throughout his play in
pogchamps he does really well in the
opening and i think the middle game is
where he struggles the most
coming up with a plan once more of the
obvious moves have already
been done yeah yeah and i think that
typically that is like the most
difficult part when you're kind of a
beginner in chess
to know what to do in the middle game
because uh
you can memorize opening moves but the
middle game you sort of have to
understand ideas and come up with plans
so that's definitely the most difficult
part
uh but yeah g3 does oh
three queen why are the queens always
gone
the queens are always gone brutality and
i cannot stand for this
every single match that i'm here there's
just so many
queens being sacrificed still win okay
let's
take a look at rubius come on have you
seen the queen
he's hovering over the bishop it's fine
it's fine everything is
fine okay if anything
i think he might even need the queen
okay
it's everything is completely okay i'm
okay
there you go nico nico is okay
boomer and she will try to
oh
let's take it back so
i see a theme in this game and it's
once you blunder your queen try to give
away the rest of your pieces
that has been what we saw in the first
game and you know what
at least it's okay and now we just hung
another
whoo because the rook is hanging on a8
wow
wow and he goes for it is he gonna see
queen takes a8 it's a long diagonal
i i think he's gonna see it he's gonna
see it but
both players did the same thing as soon
as they blunder they just
gave away everything yeah guys
almost dropped his queen there but
he took it and there you go
well now he's going to get his
confidence back d5 is a great move for
him so
the people commenting you resign now
quoting queen's
that nico isn't ready to resign just yet
but i think he is preparing the
checkmate and
it'll be nice to watch him deliver all
the way
to the checkmate which is going to mean
we are going to see a tie break between
nico and rubius
that means that we're gonna have an
armageddon match which means
white gets five minutes black gets four
minutes but draws if the position is a
draw black
gets the win the person with the higher
accuracy is going to pick which color to
play with
most people pick white because there's
very few draws
at this level of chess um so i will say
that it is kind of a rough
format to you know figure out who moves
on but at the same time it's fun and the
person who played more accurately
gets a little bit of an advantage so
seems fair enough
absolutely what color do you oh it's
five and five
new rules they changed it well great
because the old rules
sucked there i said it it's gonna be
five five
wow okay all right that's gonna be super
exciting
awesome new rules uh new rules
guys we're just we're just uh cheesing
okay let's see him
let's see him finish off the checkmate
here maybe rook hate
and then or he could take away the g5
square first
look he's going for that he is he is
doing
exactly what you said awesome and
nico has so many pawns that there are no
stalemate threats so he can feel
comfortable to just
go for the checkmate take his time and
enjoy his first win you know
he's worked hard he's taken seven
beatings in a row to finally taste
sweet victory i am sure it's like
somebody who hasn't eaten
for a few days getting their first meal
and
that's you know enough to embolden
anybody's spirits
it's going to taste very well for him
this one
look at that smile it looks like he's a
different person now
he looks so happy do you think he'll
bring out his cat
oh his cat wilson which is the most
american name
ever and i find it hilarious i know i
stole this from you because you said it
during the break sorry anna
that's okay i just i had no idea that
his cat's name was wilson and i just
i was just trying to like see him saying
hola wilson well
hang on hang on hang on hang on hang on
why is he taking all of the pawns
remember when i said there was no
stalemate chances
he is a godsend content creator so maybe
maybe he's just playing with with us
a little bit you know daddy's gotta be
careful because it's still made here
oh no don't oh nico should have gone to
c3
and and had chances to stella made her
king that would have been beautiful
uh let's not
stephen here all right
if if he takes on c5 which is what he
seems to be wanting to do as he's taking
all these pawns and
there'll just be a check meeting too and
he goes for that there you go all right
good job ruby it's very nice finish here
and
honestly kudos to nico for for not
giving a second
wait a second yeah yeah there we go
there you go anna were you a little
nervous
i was i was very nervous there
well there it is you guys rubius
one he is celebrating
[Music]
good job good job well now it is tied we
are going to see them go to the tie
breaks
it is going to be five minutes to five
minutes
and i do believe that the higher
accuracy at least picks the colors and
that does seem fair so we will be right
back
the colors and that is correct to be
clear you guys i think nico is a huge
favorite here based on how quickly she
moves i think she's a very big favorite
um
so i i would say that i think in general
she's she's a big fan oh no am i back on
oh no i have to go to puzzles
um so i would say that i think i was
gonna take a break i guess i don't get
to take a break let's go to puzzles all
right
um one sideline of course and just uh
you gotta be careful there one two three
eight
welcome back to pogchamps three
presented by grip6 we are about to see
the tiebreak match between rubius and
nico
they are going to be playing a 5-0 time
control game
nico is going to be playing white
because she had a better overall
performance in the group stage whoever
wins
is going to move on to the semifinals in
the consolation bracket
whoever loses is going to be eliminated
and banned from twitch
forever no i'm just kidding so
that's what's going happen uh rubius is
probably a little bit more spirited
nico is taking a little bit of a food
break so
that is great and uh let me remind you
guys
about what else we are gonna see today
in case you guys are thinking oh no
the games are going to be over there's
not going to be enough chess what am i
going to do
don't worry don't worry we got you
covered up next we have
ludwig playing logic they are super
close
and you know ludwig this is his third
pog champs he is certainly a pog
champs veteran logic has been training
chess every single day
quickly getting better i don't know
who's gonna win but it's gonna be
fascinating then we're gonna see
pokemane versus myth
pokemane seems to be the favorite but
myth did beat pokemane's chess.combot
and
tweeted about it so you know maybe the
salt is going to
create some kind of provocation or drama
i know the drama frogs are looking for
some fresh blood to feed their drama
needs these two matches are going to be
commentated by
hikaru and by levy so you're going to
have some pretty awesome commentators
and another surprise for you guys on
thursday february 25th
we are going to see the match between
taboo
and code miko they are going to be also
moving forward to the semi-finals of the
consolation match
code miko has been you know this really
up and coming
v tuber tubbo is part of the dream smp
and also very up-and-coming in the
minecraft and just generally twitch
world so
super fun content creators to watch and
let's remind you guys since we just had
a donation thank you so much about the
community outreach that chess.com is
doing they are matching up to a hundred
k
in community donations so far we've
almost hit 19k
and uh depending on how the participants
place they will be able to donate
different amounts to the charities
of their choice it's very exciting to
see that chess.com is helping give back
to some of the communities i think it's
always great to have a
charity component to such a big event
you can be entertained and feel good
about it
at the same time um actually absolutely
true yeah
there we go amazing wait does niko know
she's on
can can someone tell her she's on so we
don't just have an eating camp
in case she doesn't know um
or maybe or maybe maybe maybe she knows
just just want to check uh rubius is out
of his chair
and um honestly nico nico is making me
hungry too
anna what's your favorite food oh that's
a really good question
anything that has to do with pasta pasta
is amazing i also really like actually
this pan this spanish dish paella i
don't know if you've ever tried it oh
yeah i have tried that before
yeah that's one of my favorite foods
actually what's your favorite food
i love asian food my favorite kind of
asian food is japanese food i know sushi
well okay the thing about sushi is it's
a different
tier of food when sushi is
good it's so different than any other
things and it's so
beautiful to look at as well you're
always surprised
it feels so fresh and it's just it's
just the god
tear of all food people who don't like
it haven't developed
taste yet that's the only explanation
which is okay because my sister hasn't
either and you guys are a similar age
oh andrea yeah yeah awesome
go andrea it's a it's a refined case
it's a refined taste i
i feel strongly about it but um no i'm
just kidding i know a lot of people
don't like fish so no hard feelings
anna but speaking of feelings it looks
like rubius is trying to pump himself
up look at that yup
look at that that's amazing
he knows this is the game ready
smashing boys like yeah and we get it
i think he's like i think he's like
shouting all those booms in his head as
well
i kind of like it it does bring up the
energy um
i'm kind of here for it do you do
anything to pump yourself up
yeah i either listen to music or i will
listen to a motivational video i really
like those and
i used to just like you said before i
used to listen to those when i was
working out as well i like to do that
um but either that or before a chess
match those are two two times i listen
to them
that's awesome well here we go games
have started
five minutes nico has a much lower blitz
rating than rubius but i'm sure
it's not accurate and she's just been
grinding on her rapid rating
so she does get the white pieces because
she had a better performance
although i don't know about her opening
with with
white the bird seems a little bit less
safe than her black opening
um but she couldn't pick the the colors
they were assigned automatically so
let's see what's gonna happen true
true yeah although she did win her her
game with white but
she did have a very bad position out of
the opening so
it seems like her black openings are
better but we'll see what happens here
um all right because a lot of it depends
on ruby is taking
um advantage of playing you know kind of
a less accurate opening and it doesn't
seem like he's doing it
so it might actually not make a
difference d3 i don't love d4
would have put her pawn in the center
and had a little bit of a more solid
setup
that being said um again it's it's hard
to
take advantage of these small
inaccuracies
yep absolutely and i think that's
something that's really going to be
noticeable in this game
is the time management of these players
we know that nico's been playing super
fast
whereas rubios has been thinking a
little bit more but
in this game there's no increment so
when the time is gone the time is gone
there's no coming back
just like life he played bishop a5 here
he didn't take the knight he's keeping
the bishop on the board
nico is playing h3 which she always does
but it's really unnecessary there's no
even bishop that can get to g4
yeah and i i kind of like well he's
opening up the center here but i kind of
like it when winter king is still in the
center i know that the evil bar didn't
like it but
i guess it's because he's just blundered
upon right yeah yeah
he did blunder upon but it is gonna be a
double pawn that
um he can put some pressure on maybe 97
rookie eight
she will be able to oh he pushes
um and yeah i mean she can take it and
the problem is
he can't recapture because then she's
gonna grab his knight yeah
pawns are falling the pawns are falling
ons are falling i think that
he got so motivated by the video that he
just thought that he could push
anything yeah he's like throwing pawns
like
just flinging them off the board too
much adrenaline
uh rubius rubius you gotta keep some of
the pieces
and he is and he is i mean again he
plays the openings well
and he can still recover from this i
just
don't want to see the dominoes from
either of them that we saw in the first
two games
i agree now there's a really cool move
knight takes d4 that's a pawn for rubios
and he goes for it he takes it nice okay
very oh my god you're right anna queen
h4
is is ruby is gonna see this he can come
back you guys he can
basically win the game it would be
checkmate in two if he would have seen
it
or if it was his turn to move right now
because you block king goes up and then
you go queen f2
and a great eye there what can nico do
to stop this threat i think she saw it
because she slowed down
i think so but shu she didn't
stop it she would be as has checkmate in
three you guys this is the moment he's
been training for
this is what all the who's have been
shouted for and he misses it
he plays another move which is also okay
but that was his moment
to take it that was the chocolate moment
okay all right he is a piece up here now
right yes he is
he is a piece up and he doesn't know
that he missed checkmate so that's
good because he won't get down on
himself yep that's good there's nothing
to do about it now there's no more
checkmate the king will be able to
escape and that was the moment
oh no nico is pushing her king side
pawns
instead of trying to take out her bishop
and castle even though if she would have
taken out the bishop
she wouldn't have been able to block the
queen h4 check with her queen
we are seeing the same ideas as in the
first game this h3g4
and trying to go aggressive but it's not
really anything to attack us
king is very very safe on g8 right and
he needs to develop his pieces though
because his bishop on c8 and rook on e8
could be very helpful for his attack
f6 is also good because he's getting rid
of one of the center pawns
and nico's king is going to be very
exposed here
yeah it definitely is he's got to be
careful about his knight the knight is
hanging on b5 could be difficult to see
as
this d4 move is very sneaky but
he just takes it wow free pawn he grabs
it
uh he is as hungry as nico was before
the match
he got one when he likes the taste of
blood he's going in for more that's all
that's all we got to say here folks
bishop g2 niko might get her castle and
do you think there's a chance she
escapes
there might be a chance that she well
now there's not anymore oh no
she had to go for the castle um she is
up on time though
rubius is a little bit lower
yes he's a little bit lower but he's got
this great position and
it's not that as much of a time
difference as in other games that we've
seen before so it seems like rubio's
really
has thought about his time management
very
true and he has the better position and
it's easier to play fast when you're not
in pressure when you're not getting
attacked so
you know nico has pulled off um a win
before after she blundered her knight in
the first game so she is certainly a
swindle queen
and if somebody can find some way to
come back she's done it before maybe
she'll do it again
maybe she'll do it again who knows this
is going to be a very intense game
and i mean we've seen that anything can
happen
right and she played rook f1 which i
loved because if he would have taken her
king would have been
slowly getting into safety but he made a
great move
bishop e6 developing completely ignoring
the trade
so um he certainly gets a gold star for
that move
yup yup definitely trade yeah they're
exchanging
and maybe you should try queen f2
i know you shouldn't trade when you're
down but i don't like her king in the
center
i like that i think a queen f2 would be
a kind of good practical choice even
though
it shouldn't be good if the king stays
in the century might get checkmated
which is a bigger issue
right i mean the way you try to
strategize when you're down is weird
because technically everything you do
is losing but which ones give the
highest likelihood that your opponent
might make a mistake
that's how you want to prioritize your
moves rather than just
doing whatever is going to take the
longest to not get checkmated
yeah definitely there was a little fork
on b3 but
um he's saving his piece by going knight
b5 right right
he's uh he's still playing a good move
and he's he's keeping up the pace which
i like in case he needs to take some
time later on
bishop d5 is an awesome move because if
he takes
nico takes and checks the knight and the
king nico's tactics are actually
super sharp they definitely are she says
she's
she's saying okay i'm gonna do exactly
what alex said and i'm gonna make it as
difficult as possible for for rubios
even though i'm completely lost here
we're gonna make it more difficult but
rubius is getting close to one minute
and there's no increment one minute
chess is a completely
different game to play it is crazy
and uh i'm actually really excited to
see these two players get into 60-second
territory
you've been playing a lot of bullets as
well yourself alex yes i have i need to
reach 2500 bullet in the next four days
or i'm going to lose a bet and i'm going
to have to shave my head welcome to
misery ladies and gentlemen
welcome to misery um i think rubius may
have just blundered a piece though
oh my gosh because if he takes then his
knight on b5 is hanging
what is this move
everybody's learning but you could have
picked any move
why didn't we take and she sees my queen
of chew check
what a great move it wasn't a botanist
gambit but he's gonna get in
so much trouble now like technically he
should be getting mated but
it is a little tricky to see i just feel
bad because he's played so well and that
was a rough blunder to see i'm i'm not
trying to
to get heated on anyone's behalf here
yeah wow but she saw it
nico saw it you give nico anything and
she is so sharp and she will go in for
it
yup she doesn't wait okay all right so
now they're cool what happens if they
draw by the way
somehow
yeah i don't think she will but i don't
think he he will but if he finds some
kind of perpetual that's his best chance
here to try to
get in the queen and just you know
tickle the king back and forth until the
position repeats three times yeah maybe
he oh he
he misclicked i think he misclicked
that's why i was so shocked
that makes so much sense he missed
clicked before and that's just a brutal
time for it to happen
oh that really hurts all of the mouse
clips they just really hurt
he needs to try to pre-move because
maybe he can flag niko
even though he has less time and i don't
think he notices clock
ah wow what a game
wow yeah i was gonna have to pre-move
everything he's got but still 30 seconds
is a long
it's a lot of time and one second is a
little bit of time
so oh wow
that was that was quite the comeback
from nico
rubius was able to scalp one point
in the official tournament so you know
not all is lost he was able to make a
comeback
and clearly he has a lot of the uh chess
strategy down it's just those moments
where he loses focus and blunders that
have gotten him down it looks like nikko
is celebrating yeah
um but we'll be back soon with both
players for a post game interview
congratulations
to nikko and don't go anywhere
i think ruby is he's just not used to
playing blitz i think he needs to play
more blitz chess
that's all there is to it he plays more
blitz shots then it's good he's just not
used to playing blitz i think he needs
to play more blitz chess
okay let me mute myself okay let's go
back um
all right okay so here we go we're gonna
keep going with puzzles go checkmate
let's go check me let's go chuck mate
let's go check mate
let's go check mate
let's go check mate let's go check mate
let's go check mate let's go fork
let's go check mate let's go and capture
the queen
let's fork the king of the queen let's
go for chuck mate
let's go for checkmate let's
take and take the queen takes take the
rook is good uh chuck mate
here and checkmate pigs and then here
here
must be this and queen takes and taken
rook b7 when the queen here um this is
what black's playing win so it must be
this and then this
and then this this should be checked
should we take and takes
the checkmate should be takes check take
the bishop
should be takes d5 d4 take the juicer
probably check and now you've checker
queen g8 both moves
probably work um but which one is
correct
my instinct says queen g8 it's right and
i think it is
so you go check go here
here here here um
now you can take with the pawn or the
queen i'm assuming you take with a pawn
don't really understand that puzzle
chuck takes um
should be just takes takes and just
takes now you can probably make a check
you can go rook c7
uh rook c7 king 2 rook c1 is just
winning i believe
here it takes c1 and just take the
juicer
uh probably check me take here here
you should probably run the king
although you can run this way too
b5 if you go here here here here
here here here here uh it's a draw
so here here here here here here
here here here here here here here there
there there and you would just take and
come up and you win the game
take c6 just remove the pony uh queen f3
queen h6
probably just this that's good uh knight
c4 looks crushing chuck takes
um you can also take the rook take the
queen take the rook
pretty good you have bishop e4 you've
worked d3 takes takes
come back uh should be
there no i i was moving too fast that
one
going too fast all right let's go
check and take the knight and now i
think it's a bishop h4 queen h1 here
both moves work but i think it's the
wait now i'm just tanking okay let's do
one timed one um let's do a time one
let's go
go for the timed one
okay let's go checkmate checkmate take
the queen take the rook take the bishop
take the rook take the queen
check takes check
it's good checkmate checkmate
check checkmate checkmate
checkmate check check
check takes
checkmate check takes
go here take the queen um should be
chuck chuck and mate
be checkmate checks
check checkmate take the pawn make the
chuck make the check
take the queen here here take take make
a queen
um check check that's good you have
queen off to you bishop d4 you have a3
we are joined by rubius and nico this
was
a very very close match i actually have
um a position
up on the board after nico played bishop
takes c6 check
rubius was leading the entire time and
then he played king f8 was that a mouse
slip by any chance
uh no i thought okay the thing is i
thought the
she had the the queen and the king
pinned so that's why i did that i didn't
see it
through like i didn't think about it i i
i was convinced that
the queen and the king was where pinned
both of them
well you were also in time pressure and
what we noticed throughout the match is
you would play the opening
very very well and then in time pressure
that was when we'd see a little bit of a
slip up
but um still you played a very strong
tactical game
and nico congratulations for fighting
through it and coming back we were
looking we thought there's no way nico
can save this
and then as soon as you had an
opportunity you went for it i mean
you must have been doing a ton of
tactics nico is that true
um i think my brain was working on
overtime because
uh i was starting to feel very nervous
and intimidated like at first i was like
okay this is gonna be like
a good game we're both pretty equally
matched but when he like
when i did that queen slip i started
feeling clammy and i was like
yeah yeah we both feel generous on the
both games
it was very exciting to watch but yeah
nico you felt like every time you got an
opportunity you
you just took it you played so well so
big congrats on
on the win really good thank you
absolutely and i know both of you guys
stream in spanish i mean rubios you're
one of the biggest creators
on the entire site tick tock's one of
sorry niko's one of the biggest creators
on tick tock
um yeah well hey you know we're generous
we're gonna go we're gonna go with that
also so rubius are you going to continue
to uh play chess after pogchamps how are
you feeling after the tournament
yes of course i like now i'm more
motivated than never to
to win the next pog times which is
pokestops4 right yeah four so
remember my name because i will be there
at the finals with
whoever wins that game i love it i love
the confidence um
and nico you're gonna be going into the
semifinals do you have any special
preparation
or anything you're planning on doing um
i definitely need to get
more lessons like i i only took a lesson
with you guys you and andrea and anna
and i'm trying to get like
one with anna and then also with the
other
anna and hopefully you guys could also
give me one more before
you know the semifinals because uh i i
feel like i haven't brushed up on
anything since the snow storm last week
and then coming back to dallas and then
moving
right after so haven't had time for
anything so hopefully i could get some
some uh some lessons in yeah absolutely
we'll be around if you need any help and
i'm sure the entire chess community
would be more than happy to
give you some aid you will be playing
the winner of tubbo versus code miko but
um before we get into that actually anna
does speak spanish so i think it'd be
fun for the spanish viewers if maybe we
switch it up a little bit
yeah i mean this is gonna feel so weird
i always feel so weird when i've been
speaking english for like
three hours straight and i start
speaking spanish
um
foreign
[Music]
a
foreign
[Music]
oh
uh nico congratulations and good luck in
the semi-finals of rubius
you know what we'll see you in pog
champs four and at least you have wilson
to
cheer you up um thank you guys so both
for
doing the interview thank you so much
thank you no thank you guys
see ya bye everyone
so up next you guys we are gonna see
nico playing the winner of tubbo versus
code miko
later today we're gonna see pokemane
versus myth
and um later on in the week mr beast
versus michelle
care so we're just gonna show you guys
the schedule for the rest of the day
because we are actually going to be
leaving it has been a blast hanging out
with all the pepes in chat
but hikaru and levy are going to be
swapping with us they're going to be
covering
ludwig versus logic and pokemane versus
myth
um but we had a great time and anna
it was honestly really fun doing
commentary with you i know we streamed
before you always bring the energy
and uh hopefully we'll be able to do
this again sometime
definitely was super fun to be here i'm
so happy that that i was able to join
you here for this commentary of pog
champs and
yeah it's it's been amazing and levy and
hikaru will be absolutely great so
yeah it's going to be fun to see what
happens in the next matches
and alex good luck as well on on your
challenge i have to say that before i go
good luck i'm not gonna go bald it's all
gonna be fine everybody
um i'll be tuning in and watching some
of the pogchamps as well until then
we're going to have a short break
hope everybody enjoys the rest of the
games take care
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
come on
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
roof